the White House has released its
Christmas video and a lot of people are
saying it's cringe it's creepy and it
looks like the Hunger Games but I don't
care too much about that I mean if
they're going to put out a bad piece of
art well you know people do that all the
time but it turns out the group behind
it is actually a racist organization
whose uh uh uh pred their their mission
is pred at upon racism it's actually
kind of interesting the White House
chose to choose a racist hate group is
what many people are saying and it is
true their website is loaded with an uh
with racist propaganda and things of
that sort so I I I I can I figure we're
getting so close to Christmas let's talk
about what we are doing here with these
uh uh uh holidays but we do have a bunch
of other news Hunter Biden is telling
people he may have to flee the country
if Donald Trump is elected oh boy and
then we got a bunch of other silly news
we'll get into a lot um Mickey Mouse as
of January 1st will be public domain
only the early iteration of Mickey Mouse
so take for that uh what you will and
then we have some really big news some
more serious news a journalist and
contributor to The Blaze TV has just
announced he he he will have to
surrender next Tuesday to the feds he is
being criminally charged over January 6
for his actions as a
reporter it's only to get worse from
there I saved the worst for last there's
going to be many other journalists who
will likely be charged many who already
have been some who've already fled the
country and then from there 2024 is
going to get absolutely wild before we
get started my friends head over to
Historic mail.com timcast today's
episode is sponsored by historic mail
it's an amazing gift opportunity it's
one of the coolest things I've seen in a
long time think about this gift for the
holidays sending your family members and
actual letter from a historical figure
like Benjamin Franklin Thomas Edison
George Washington Abraham Lincoln with
information surrounding this letter and
explaining exactly what the letter was
all about so it's a great gift the
American History gift package Treasure
Trove it spans letters from 1776 the
birth of the Republic to 1976 the height
of the Cold War presidents like
Washington Lincoln FDR alongside
alongside iconic figures such as Walt
Disney Tesla and Twain it's a journey
through pivotal M pivotal moments in
American history and for that history
lover in your life historic mail is the
ultimate gift you can even make it
personal by sending a beautiful gift
certificate with both your names on it
it's a touch of class that adds to the
magic this is a good script by the way
I'm loving it here's the exciting part
this podcast is sponsored by historic
mail that's right they've got a
Christmas sale going on and you can
enjoy 10% off on all products so this
holiday season surprise your loved ones
with the gift of History head over to
Historic male
timcast now and you'll get your gift
cards and your 10% off check it out
thank you historic mail for uh
sponsoring the show I'm a big fan this
sounds really really awesome and I and I
and I you guys know I love reading about
history especially Civil War history
I've been reading a ton of that stuff so
definitely also head over to the bestest
song ever.com
tonight midnight the song drops timcast
teaming up with the daily wire we
covered the song from Smoky Mike and the
god king and we did it because their
song was basically a
$150,000 middle finger to the woke music
industry that told them they were not
allowed to play a classic song this is
crazy they offered 100 times the market
rate and they were still told no so
Jeremy boring was like okay then I'll
spend that money and we'll make our own
and when I heard that I said we've got
to we've got to also mock the music
industry because they're Gatekeepers if
you don't align with their politics they
don't let you in the front door if
you're a smaller musician they give you
the boot and a lot of lot of people I
think have experienced this so This song
that we're putting out together again
it's a cover of their song it's not a
political song but the point is we
teamed up with them to put out a song a
modern version basically the whole song
is a mockery of the mainstream pop music
apparatus and if you pre-order the song
right now or buy it tomorrow when it's
live not only do you get the song for 69
cents you get 35% off all cast brew.com
purchases that's coffee including
subscription so get this you want to
subscribe to the coffee Club you want to
subscribe to one bag per month if you
buy the song and get that code you will
keep that discount
forever only if you subscribe in the
next two weeks when the song comes up so
uh definitely support our work with this
music it the whole thing is basically
meant to be silly and funny and very
very goofy and it will be live uh
midnight tonight go to the best song
ever.com also become a member at
timcast.net coming up for you tonight at
10: p.m. you don't want to miss it it'll
be good fun smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and everything else is
Cara castronova hey thank you for having
me who are you what do you do I'm Cara
castronova and I'm a former champion
boxer I now am a contributor at Newsmax
and at the Gateway pundit and um you
know I specialize for the most part in
covering stuff pertaining to January 6th
and everything that happened that day
and I really got my start when during
the lockdowns when I started being an
activist against the lockdowns and
against the for mandates with the
vaccines and it just took off from there
for me and I've been you know doing news
reporting and writing investigative
pieces which I really like to do that's
my favorite thing is investigating and
writing stories that nobody else is
writing right on thanks for hanging out
should be fun we got Lukowski of we are
change hey guys my name is Lukowski of
we change.org and I'm running a holiday
special for
$7,000 I'm selling on blank blank 7,000
uh a load if you want to see what the
blank means means you have to go to the
best political shirts.com I wear this
shirt all over Miami and the mamas
absolutely love it uh you're single dude
check out the best political shirts.com
everyone hello I'm Ian cwell and happy
to be here uh I I don't have a lot to
report except that I studied the
invention of the radio last night after
we got into it AM radio is amplitude
modulation whereas FM is frequency
modulation very cool stuff and it was
Marone the Italian guy that gets the
credit for building that thing Tesla may
have been involved a lot of people work
but it was really Herz that uh kind of
discovered the electromagnetic waves and
so you know we named it after him and
you can uh you can use some of the
technology to capture free energy I
think I think I watch Myth MythBusters
do this they uh a radio receiver
converts uh EMF waves into current very
very weak but that's basically how part
of Tesla's uh his uh Warden Cliff Tower
was he was trying to send like Global
radio from this Tower he ran out of
money partway through I wonder if he was
going to do a double whammy and and
produce electricity and radio that would
have been cool he was working on some
out of this world stuff I did a secret
society in-depth kind of analysis on uh
Tesla uh holy cow there's a lot of
things down the rabbit hole with this
top and it was Trump's Uncle who uh was
actually the one who found him after his
he passed away was the first Federal
Officer inside of his you know and
apparently seized the remaining
technology that I just felt like we were
in a simulation things are things are
really synchronizing yeah Marina BR
mit's brother is a part of a a Tesla
secret society in Serbia that I actually
talked to that's cool well we'll save
that for a culture War episode on
Aliens we got Serge pressing the buttons
uh yeah I'm here I'm glad you're looking
up on radios good stuff surge.com
everybody whenever you're ready Tim here
we go we got the story from the New York
Post Jill Biden's bizarre Hunger Games
aesthetic White House Christmas video
roasted by critics uh you know the first
thing I said earlier today was like you
know I don't care if they want to do
some cringe tap dancing thing but
apparently a lot of people are like yo
this is one of the worst things we've
ever seen scene and for that you will
all now have to watch it along with
us it's really bad it's really H do I
have to I have to unmute
it it is really really bad and this is
physically in the White House in the
White House I believe it is yeah it
looks like The Shining like you expect
the kids from The Shining to pop up out
of here candy cane walls are a little
much hey very diverse okay say that
again yeah look at that look how she
stares oh yeah it's like they're doing
stage acting but they're doing it on
camera that's why it looks so weird this
is what all the all the victims of MK
Ultra see before they're hijacked and
taken over and brought to the CIA secret
black sites in order to commit their
assassinations on political leaders this
is the brainwashing campaign talented
dancers but this is like what you look
at from 100 30 300 feet away so that's
why their their faces are so I I'm sorry
I I got to be honest I I hate tap
dancing I absolutely despise tap dancing
why though it just it's like nails on a
chalk right that that's it like nails on
a chalkboard that's what that sounds
like to me I tap daned when I was
younger so I like it but I didn't like
that definitely I think just the only
thing miss him was like Dylan mulany
like he should have been in there yo I'm
not going to rag on people for wanting
to do a tap dancing Christmas that
doesn't matter to me but then I saw this
this is from The Daily Mail Jill Biden's
White House Christmas dance troop our
radical BLM loving activists who have
demanded prison abolition and defunding
the police but it's not just that people
are calling it a racist hate group a
large portion of their background is
ragging on People based on race and so
the White House decided to bring in a
group to dance around smiling when
they're like explicitly saying on their
website they hate you based on your race
like that that was kind of wild to me
and that I think is worthy of more
criticism now you add these two things
together and you get a trashy
performance I don't care for but you're
allowed to like it I don't you know if
people on the left want to like it's
fine whatever but they're just a bunch
of racists I don't like racists Hunter
Biden liked it after smoking some uh
irck like substances but that guy likes
a lot of different weird stuff so uh
definitely a lot of things reminiscing
of of Hunger Games here that a lot of
people are making a lot of comparisons
to absolutely but the organization does
a lot of weird stuff they they they I I
think they're more of an activist
organization than a dance organization
they're kind of a collective
organization of radical feminists of
color they call for prison abolition
they call for defunding the police they
tell people to join their local black
lives matter chapter and more
importantly they say hey if you're white
you got to check your privilege and you
got to learn how to be mindful and
financially support other people because
you were born the wrong skin color and
therefore you are a bad person that's
extensively what they are saying they
say they say that if you take issue with
being insulted based on your race you
are
fragile and so I I see things like that
and I'm just like dude there was that um
that little kid who was wearing the the
the face paint for the chief's game and
he had black on one side and red on the
other and it was a a black reporter who
complained about uh black face and I
said that's black fragility that's what
black fragility is he he sees a kid
wearing Chief's face paint and he loses
his mind and calls it all racism and I'm
like you see why you you shouldn't do
that I'm not going to go and blame all
black people because one yelled at
a kid but that's what people like this
do they say that if you're a white
person who doesn't like being insulted
based on the color of your skin you have
white fragility I'm like well like one
white person was upset about it I don't
I don't know that every single white
person gets mad when you criticize a
white person that black reporter who
wanted to get that kid in trouble for
whatever reason he's one guy he doesn't
represent all black people I'm s I'm
like it makes no sense to make black the
focus of it the same way they make white
the focus of it this is my problem with
leftist identitarians and being brought
into the White House I think it's
disgusting they don't get angry they get
perturbed okay well it's just so
hypocritical like the it's like the
Reverse Racism stuff that's happening
you know I'm have Chinese and half
Italian I don't really think about that
much but I just I feel kind of bad for
white guys in the present day like I
just feel like they are really under
attack in many ways and white women like
when the whole Karen thing I feel like
it's a very racist term to call somebody
a Karen to call White it's become a
racist term yeah but you know Reverse
Racism would be a good thing the idea
that you get a bunch of racists like
this and you reverse what they've done
but what they're actually is just racist
right it's the left uses this language
game they call it Reverse Racism when
they attack white people because they
want to make it seem like they're not
being racist when like quite literally
that's all they're doing hating People
based on their race yeah the antidote to
racism is seeing people as humans right
you know it's got got worse and I think
progressively like I think there's more
racism now than there was 20 years ago
like the early 2000s say the way I
remember it I don't remember even ever
thinking about race and now all of a
sudden it's the only thing that we're
fixated on what's your race what's your
sexual identity like these things
weren't things I spoke about when I was
in my late teens and early 20s a lot of
people blame Obama I I liked him in the
early days I was like he's a cool guy
and I didn't really care what he looked
like I was just listening to him and
looking into his eyes and like but then
he I guess like he would say things
about race and like and bring it up and
kind of create a polarization let's
watch this one here you
[Music]
go this is the first lady milania's
Christmas video it is remarkably
neutral it's very white though that's
problematic those trees are too white
it's one lady she's white I'm talking
about the trees white light they said
that the white lights on the trees were
symbolic of like you know white supr
suemac no lights of color right so so in
this video a lot of people are comparing
the two videos are saying melania's was
better we don't we don't need to hear
from Peter Ducey right now they're
saying melania's was better because hers
was just a very neutral this is the
White House on Christmas I got to say
I'd call it lowest common denominator
meaning it was wasn't really much of
anything everybody got to see the White
House it was Christmas time how how nice
right I actually hey look I think it's
great that the the White House
celebrated Christmas I think the way
they celebrated it was kind of tacky but
it's fine not everybody has to like what
I like and I don't have to like what you
like but don't bring a bunch of racists
in to do it man pisses me off I got a
little Disturbed at them I mean it's
like it is the White House and it is the
capital and like but they decked it out
with a lot of like Gody like furniture
and trees and decorations and like
people are I don't want to speak for
everyone but a lot of people I think the
economy is right I going to point that
out like there's so many people
suffering and they're putting they're
tap dancing on America's casket ESS
they're tap dancing and everyone being
financially ruined but this is why
they're calling it Hunger Games yeah no
absolutely sorry car I cut you off no it
was okay I was just going to say that
you know it just it is a smack in the
face I think to a lot of people in
America who especially in the lower
classes who really are suffering from
the economy and I didn't like I don't
consider myself lower income I'm right
in the middle so I think the people in
the lower income communities feel it the
most cuz I go out and talk to people all
the time for my job reporting for
Newsmax and Gateway pundit and you know
it's it's a real thing like people
literally living paycheck to paycheck
like they spend their last $10 on that
day's lunch so I think to put a video
like that up and like use people of
color as always as tokens um is is
offensive to people that are literally
starving and don't have money for food
and then they're putting up these like
tap dancers tap dancing around the White
House with like candy canes and these
crazy glitzy God decorations especially
especially with all the resources now
going to Illegal immigration and helping
them out as there are a lot of Mainline
stories of a lot of communities
specifically poor communities being
denied resources that they had before
that are now being diverted to of course
the new Democratic voting base that is
literally being shipped into this
country right but they're they're
they're really out of touch I think that
that's a pandering move what they did
there it's like they're pandering to for
like the diversity and inclusion stuff I
don't even think people like minorities
are really into that like they just want
to be able to pay their bills and the
economy to approve they're not impressed
with that especially people that I talk
to you know but it's not but but here's
the thing it's not for them right Jill
Biden didn't produce this video for poor
people she produced it for her peers you
know when I worked at Vice we were uh uh
constantly talking about content to make
and what the strategy was and I was
always just wondering why it was that
the higher-ups of the company were so
focused on cable television I was like
who cares and I understand it's
guaranteed contract money it's like you
sign a 10-year deal for terrestrial
cable and you get guaranteed Revenue
coming in through the cable
subscriptions and all that stuff that I
understood but I was like that's not
going to build your bra up and then I
realized it rather
quickly Shane Smith and the other people
who were higher ups were in their
mid-40s mid to late 40s their whole
world was being on TV they did not grow
up with the internet the way we did and
so as the younger guys in our 20s were
looking at how to get online and
maximize viewership he was chasing the
Caboose of the trend that had already
left the station that's exactly what I
thought out of touch that was the exact
words that went through my mind when
when I saw this first I was like Jill
and Joe are so out out of touch with
what's going on exactly Joe Biden is not
thinking about poor people in this
country she's going I wonder what people
would like what does people mean people
means the 1% It means the people who
make 600 plus thousand a year and she's
like o they'll really like this you know
there's some kind of sociopathic PR guy
at the White House who's like we're
losing the black vote we're losing the
election we're not doing that well I got
an idea let's get black people smiling
and dancing that's going to show
everyone that they're really happy right
guys and like yeah yeah sure Bob yeah
sure and then they do this and then and
then it's like what what the crap what
the freaking hell is this bull crap it
almost what is that that old stuff that
they used to do when they would have
like people in Black La tap dancing it
was that old school form of
entertainment it kind of remove reminds
me of that yeah they could have toned it
down for camera at least like the whole
like right like that stuff keep that for
the stage yeah yeah yeah it's a little
you're gy a I like that's the way you
described it I think so but you know I
want to stress this I think a lot of
people are ragging on the performance
and I'm just like H that comes off as so
partisan like oh I just don't like the
way they're dressed and they're T
dancing and I'm like well I mean I don't
like it either but I don't care I mean
but if we want to make an argument about
what the White House should be and
decorum and all that stuff that I get
that I get that's more what it's about
because they were I thought they were
doing a great job dancing just hands
down I didn't want to just insult it for
the sake of insulting it they're good
dancers and it was actually the mouth
movements were like what the hell are
you doing that's that's that's what it
is that's the traditional like style
like like you was saying it's like stage
work but they're doing it on camera it's
weird oh minstral shows was what you
were talking about Minal shows right
when they're when they sort of like
subjugate minorities and black people to
dancing and tap dancing on stage that's
what that reminded me of a minstral show
I it just looks it just looks kind of
weird and then when if you look at Art
architecture movies uh models and and
everything else in our society if if
it's woke it's it's kind of trash and
and I think that's that's not an
accident I think this is meant to beat
down the human spirit I think this is an
attack on beauty because once you attack
that you attack the human Spirit and the
human will to kind of live and survive
you look around the Democratic areas
there's not a lot of energy that is good
there there's not a lot of spirit
there's not a lot of growth there's not
a lot of potential it's all regressive
it's all low vibrational and I don't
think that's an accident I think this
ugliness is being thrown on us
deliberately in many different ways all
around us culturally because what better
way to subjugate and destroy a
population than to make it ugly I would
have loved just a video of Jill and Joe
sitting by a tree lighting a candle and
then saying or it's saying we're all in
this together even though there's crap
going on in the world just something
simple and unifying would have been nice
well let's let's keep the spirit of
Christmas alive with this story from
cnr.com Christian former military
officer beheads satanic Shrine in Iowa
state capital the world may tell
Christians to submissively accept the
leg legitimization of Satan but none of
the founders would have considered
government sanction of satanic altars
inside capital buildings as protected by
the First Amendment uh I
disagree I I actually I half agree I do
think that there were there were
obscenity laws and there were moral
standards and as much as the founding
fathers did believe in free speech I
still think they would have been morally
outraged at the idea of a SAT satanic
Altar and at that point I think
Constitution wouldn't even have mattered
back then today it's a different story
but here's the story Michael Cassidy a
Christian and former military officer
tore down and beheaded the Satan alter
in the Iowa capital on Thursday we're
now learning that Turning Point USA is
pledging $110,000 to the legal fund of
Michael Cassidy Christian veteran who
beheaded s satanic Idol in Iowa state
capital well I'm going to ask Luke what
he thinks first cuz he's the he's the
anarchist over here yeah same thing is
he confirm satanic listen there's a lot
of demon worshippers inside of the
government that's a fact now do you have
freedom of of religion do you have
freedom of of speech and expression I I
think so as well and I think we we have
to understand that there's a delicate
kind of uh line that we have to go down
here as of course we still got to
respect people's individuals Liberty uh
but let's call out the Satanist as well
um you don't have to resort to to BLM
tactics in order to kind of express your
opinion was it actually satanic or
was it has Baff and the Tenant of
Satanism and all that stuff and uh you
know I I am not a fan of Satanism I am
not ignorant to Satanism I've read their
tenants I understand what they're saying
I'm not a fan of it I also think Luke
get the nail on that with hammer you
shouldn't resort to BLM tactics don't
legitimize the thing the left the things
that left does do when they don't want
to go through the proper procedure and
policy I think the challenge here would
be to counter it through the system
because we want to maintain stability
and Order and in fact I'd argue this is
the exact response the left was hoping
for yeah I mean I'm a free I mean I'm a
a constitutional absolutist I do believe
every religion should like if we can't
accept satanic even though I don't
accept satanic people I don't think
there's anything valid in what they
believe but I have to respect the fact
that this is their religion then one day
you know what what could happen if
Christianity is abandoned that I don't
think that that's far off from happening
so unfortunately we have to kind of
accept the beliefs of these people and I
guess their statue that they had there
was in response to something like I
think that there was a a monument The
Ten Commandments and then they wanted to
put the satanic statue up to say there
they want their freedom of religion yeah
listen most government bureaucrats are
secret demons if they're open out in the
open overt demons yeah tell me more
about it I want to know that that you're
demon um and and attacking it again if
if the shoe was on the other foot if
this was a Satanist attacking a
Christian symbol people would have a
very different reaction than they are
right now kind of complimenting this but
I do want to stress this Satanism is not
necessarily the worship of Satan and I
think it's important we can go through
what was actually on that altar cuz I'll
tell you this right now woke people in
this country are not satanists according
to the satanic temple and the people who
are with the satanic temple do not
actually follow their own tenants such
as the first one should strive to act
with compassion and empathy toward all
creatures in accordance with reason well
we know for a fact they don't do that I
mean you don't go go go around smashing
uh buildings smashing Windows starting
fires and attacking people that's not
compassion the struggle for justice is
an ongoing anary Pursuit that should
never preva over laws and institutions
that's funny they've captured the
institutions and used laws to destroy
the lives of people during the mandates
and the lockdowns so it doesn't seem
like they follow that tenant one's body
is inviable subject to one's own will
alone now that one really gets me going
right there what does that mean one's
one's body is inviable what is that it
means that no one can uh uh penetrate
your body nobody can interfere with your
body yeah huh ain't that a good one this
like chaotic liian something what
happened to that one three years ago the
freedoms of others should be respected
they threw that out the window including
the freedom to offend yeah they threw
that out the window to willfully and
just unjustly encroach on the freedoms
of other is to forego uh one's own
beliefs should conform to One's best
scientific understanding of the world
wow they really threw that one out the
window people are fallible they they
threw that out the window when it came
to fouchy that's for sure if one makes a
mistake one should do One's best to
rectify it every tenant is a guiding
principle designed to inspire nobility
and action and thought the spirit of
compassion wisdom and Justice should
always Prevail over the written or
spoken word it sounds like it's a
chaotic religion uh like d and it's not
lawful it's not because it's like good
and righteousness should Prevail Over
Law and Orders I'll I'll tell you what
it comes off to me it's people who are
secular atheists who created a religion
for the sake of a position in religious
arguments they use Satan specifically as
a way to insult and offend the majority
religion in the country in the world
Christianity and then they make what
many people would find to be reasonable
statements as a means of convincing you
you Satan is good is it Lucifer is that
the same thing I believe Lucifer was
like the angel of Light and like
knowledge so I think yeah I believe
they're different but I don't know
enough about we have freedom of religion
in this country and people could believe
whatever they want to believe in if they
want to believe in some like meatball
pineapple thing in the sky go ahead we
have the right here in America to do
this some politicians don't believe in
that personal Liberty uh including
individuals like Ronda santis that
talked about this very specific issue
saying that he wouldn't allow it and he
doesn't view this as a legitimate
religion just because you don't
recognize a religion doesn't mean it's a
it's not a religion for some it is a
religion for Islam I it's not my
religion I disagree with it I think a
lot of the tenants should be called out
especially within the government but
using government Force to go after
people's religion is something that I am
absolutely allergic to in verse two
think about the tenants I read where
they say something like your body is
subject to your own will freedom should
be respected respect act don't don't
distort science all these things they
want you to agree with these things is
are reasonable and then say see isn't
Satan good right that's that's the game
they're playing the these tenants have
nothing to do with what Satan represents
they're trying to it's it's it's like
cult uh cult building they will present
you something very reasonable like hey
would you like to join our club we serve
pizza on Fridays and you're like wow I
would love to come to a pizza party then
when you show up they lock the doors and
start preaching about Satan like Satan
is it the devil I think they they try to
use Satan as an analogy or you know for
knowledge and and Science and and
finding the truth and and Justice like
say it like you know to to uh not it's a
it's a way to just like I don't know
like question authority to question
authority to to not fall I guess for
like other religions that you know
morality I don't know I mean I I I'm
going to look into it though but you
know like I do believe that it's
something that has to be protected
though Rhonda Sanders was asked about
this in Iowa and he said it was Trump's
fault because it was a trump administ
Administration that officially
recognized the SAT the the satanic
temple as a religion and he said I would
he said he wouldn't do it right Luke he
I know that he said he said uh the Trump
Administration gave them approval to be
under the IRS as a religion it it very
well may be because of that ruling under
Donald Trump that they may have had the
legal leg to stand on my view is that
it's not a religion quote Ronda santz
and he said more than that he said not
religion the founding fathers were
trying to create well that's subjective
I the founding fathers weren't trying to
create religion right and I think it's
danger I mean I Rona santis is my second
choice but after Trump but I think a lot
of the things he says are dangerous when
it comes to speech and when it comes to
religion like these type of things I
don't think it's fair to Define
someone's religion really I don't as
much as as abhor it is just the same way
with speech like you know people used to
say I'll defend your right to say
whatever you want even though I think
it's disgusting nowadays that's
completely not the way it is anymore
more so I do feel like we have to defend
religions that are horrible like
Satanism I'm assuming and terrible
speech you know people the ACLU used to
protect the KKK the clu clux plan this
this is multiculturalism and this is why
it don't work is it is this in a
political building was it where they is
it righteous for people to put up
religious icons in political buildings
no and they shouldn't have done it so
the the the Ten Commandments is the
mistake here is the one the Ten
Commandments going up was like the thing
that set this off they wanted to sort of
counter to counter The Ten Commandments
there there is no reality in which a
righteous Christian person will tolerate
satanic imagery being put in their
buildings and at the same time secular
atheists and woke cultists will not
tolerate
Christian Christian governance yes so
multiculturalism it it it won't work he
said quote I saw this Blasphemous statue
and was outraged my conscience is held
captive to the word of God not to
bureaucratic decree and so I acted I
mean I could see myself doing that I I
know that sounds terrible like people
have bad tempers but like if I saw a
satanic statue I mean I would have to
pay pay the price if you know get
arrested probably pay a fine and maybe
even go to jail but like you know people
become infuriated when they see that
type of thing if I saw a satanic statue
in a government building I might chop
this head off that's the attitude of BLM
right and I'm it's an emotional attitude
and but I'm not saying that I wouldn't
be subject to the law then that then I
wouldn't be arrested or or have to pay a
fine and you know face the public
there's value to being calm in the face
of being taunted cuz this was obviously
someone was trying to taunt somebody
with this and uh it worked yeah James
Lindsay had retweeted something earlier
about this uh someone made a meme video
the left uses this tactic of mid-level
violence we've talked about it a bit
it's the I'm not touching you tactic
they they showed a video where a woman
was sprinkling glitter on conservatives
heads and the cop came up to her and
said you've just committed assault if
you do it again you'll be removed and he
goes I didn't touch them right well you
don't need to touch someone to commit
assault uh depending on the jurisdiction
but this is the game they play
attempting to provoke a reaction from
you so that you look like the aggressor
and look unreasonable well it's a very
real my response with that to that was
very simple I'm like if someone
sprinkles something over you just start
gagging and fall down and then throw up
and say that they they M you or
something that's the soccer tactic if
exactly play play the soccer game if
they're going to sprinkle something on
you then you need to overreact like
they're trying to do something so
minimal to you that when you react you
give the escalation and your escalation
creates the appearance
sprinkling glitter on most people goes
unnoticed you swatting their hand away
now looks like you struck them for no
reason like and you fall down and then
your friend goes he's allergic man he's
allergic to aluminum dioxide what you
what are you doing man and then call the
police they poisoned him they poisoned
him all of a sudden everyone's like whoa
what happened like that lady was
spraying with something you got to play
soccer with these people because they're
trying to play soccer with you so when
they put the satanic imagery in the
capital smacking it is exactly what they
wanted right now they're going to come
out and they're going to make a bunch of
propaganda based off of it they're going
to say that the right is intolerant
doesn't respect Free Speech they're
going to say the right doesn't respect
the First Amendment they're going to say
things like they never believed in free
speech in the first place Etc ET this
sounds like half a story what happened
to the Ten Commandments thing that
started it all off well that's not a
part of the story so I don't know I
wonder if they tore that down and or
maybe it's a different area tough to say
well what you said about you know the
left doing this stuff like for example
in when I'm sometimes reporting in New
York they do this thing where they put
their umbrella in front of your camera
and the police can't do anything about
it the like they're not touching you or
they'll just put they'll take umbrellas
and put it in front of your face so you
can't see and then if you push it away
you could get in trouble and it's like
this you got to play soccer it's
infuriating it is you have to really sit
there and just like calm your temper
down because you just want to take the
umbrella and break it but then you're
breaking someone's property even though
they're Maring you that's they're trying
to get you to do nonphysical
interference is is interesting if
someone held up an umbrella it's you
know what I use the Frasier example it's
an old classic episode of Frasier so uh
Fraser crane is enjoying a nice a a cup
of coffee in his favorite seat at his
local cafe he's in a rather bad mood and
he gets up to go get stirrers or
something and when he comes back there's
a man sitting in his chair he's fed up
he had a bad day he says sir you're
sitting in my seat the guy tells him to
screw off Frasier gets mad picks the guy
up and throws him out that guy files
charges and sues Frasier for assault and
battery and now Frasier's in trouble
it's going to cost him a ton of money
what do I do at the end of the episode
he confronts the guy and Niles Frasier's
brother walks up and says you listen in
here you're suing my brother and you're
in the wrong the guy folling the lawsuit
then says no you listen to me and pokes
his chest and then Niles goes whoa and
falls over and smashes into a table and
he goes counter suit counter suit thus
ending the whole thing and the guy's
like I didn't I didn't I didn't do
anything to him they're like we saw you
you hit him you hit him and he fell down
that's the game they're trying to play
with you the problem is people on the
right are so Noble and honorable they're
like I I I won't do that the left knows
that the right is trying to play fair
and so they know they can play dirty
better example Jack pic gets punched in
public on camera the police witness it
happen and pull up antifa says no it
didn't it didn't happen I didn't see
anything happen what are you talking
about lying fortunately the police
watched it happen and arrested the guy
but that's the game they're playing with
you so I don't think God it I don't
think that God cares about iconography
like if you're in a room surrounded by
evil looking satanic imagery and you
stay calm God will be pleased that is
what you're supposed to you're not
supposed to freak out in the eyes of
like being taunted perhaps but uh Thou
shalt not have false false Idols is I
believe that's one of the Commandments
which one is that the second one yeah I
thought that was number two it is the
second commandment but then false Idols
could be anything it could be a lot of
people say the Catholic saints are false
Idols I mean I'm Catholic but I'm just
saying that's what people say like
Saints are false Idols I think if you
worship a human that that is a false
idol personally like we're not supposed
to worship people that makes no sense
that's that's why I get edgy about Jesus
like the people worship Jesus I think
it's a false idol no but you can Revere
people for their Good Deeds I agree but
worship God but but acknowledge that
humans I mean to say that Jesus is God
it's like that is a Christian belief
that Jesus is God that's what I believe
Jes and I am named for uh St Timothy and
do you know what he is the saint of oh
yeah good digestion yes that's right St
Timothy is the patron saint of
gastrointestinal distress I love the
Saints I think they're super legit like
I when when you when you're having gut
problems you pray to sa I would think
Jesus is a saint like I would consider
him saint Jesus instead of worrying
about in the Christian religion he's the
son of God who died on the cross to you
know make Man live forever so he's more
than God I mean he is God of
God yeah you're preaching to the choir
man I I I know the
story let's let's jump to this story
this one's where this is where things
are getting big so the other day we're
all watching this trailer for a movie
called Civil War and everyone's like oh
gez is this predictive programming I
don't know but you want to know what
we'll make predictions for you what will
be another grain of sand actually this
is a boulder not a grain of sand Blaze
journalist who covered January 6 to be
charged by Biden
doj the fascinating thing here Richie
mcginness who is a friend of the show he
was uh uh he covered the uh kosha riots
he actually tendered Aid to the man who
was shakal R house was also there at
January 6 with credentials as a
journalist and he posted an image of him
with Steve Baker a contributor to The
Blaze
and someone who is unambiguously a
journalist he said 3 months ago I had a
drink with Steve and told him the doj
would not be so partisan that they would
charge him for his work his his obvious
work as a journalist well he tweeted
this my attorney has just been notified
by the FBI that I'm going to be charged
by the justice department for my
journalistic efforts on January 6 I have
to self-surrender on Tuesday charges are
yet unknown stay tuned for more
information to follow this
afternoon scary I I I I've warned about
this and I said it was coming they are
now they they've already gone from if
you weren't even at January 6 20 years
in prison they are now at the EUR
journalist who covered it before this
Owen Shroyer permitted protest did not
go in the building uh uh Owen and Alex
Jones had permits to be at the capital
for a rally and Owen Shroyer was yelling
in the bullhorn they put him in prison
for this for a couple months The Next
Step journalist he was there doesn't
matter they're going to lock him up
despite the fact this guy is like as
journalist as a journalist gets right
the next step I believe is going to be
and I hope y'all are listening to this
one prominent personalities on social
media who have podcasts and vodcasts who
were cheering for January 6 before it
happened and on the day of will be
charged I will I will bet a large sum of
money they will be charged you want to
know why because Enrique tario was not
there but he he posted on I think it was
parlor don't leave they said that was
instruction and incitement and for that
as the leader of the proud boys 20 years
well I was that INRI taro's trial and
what you're saying makes a lot of sense
actually and there's a really novel
legal theory that they use there that a
lot of people don't know about because
no one covered it which was um it was
it's called the tools theory that even
if you're not there and I think they
were planning on using this with Trump
and and they use Enrique toio kind of as
a pseudo Trump um you could use people
in the crowd as your tool so like if
you're on your podcast saying you know
be there it's going to be wild it's
going to be great they could say that
every single person there you Ed as a
tool and this is literally what they
convicted Enrique tario with was using
the tools Theory so what you're saying
absolutely makes sense and Jamie Raskin
already played a video montage of
numerous personalities cheering for
serious action I'm not going to quote
any of them I'll I'll keep that one uh
but you can easily find some of these
quotes but let me just tell you there
were people who are prominent social
media personalities who make videos who
were in before like the day before they
were saying things like go there and
enter they were saying things like that
right they were saying more extreme
things than that these people are going
to be arrested and I think they know it
because I can tell you this some of
these people have already flip-flopped
right at so you've got people who before
January 6 were saying things like people
should go there and people should do X Y
and Z there's video of this they've
played at the January 6 committee
hearings shortly after January 6th when
they arrest everybody these people
flipped their script they're now super
anti-trump gee I wonder why I wonder why
I say like Jenna Ellis right working
with Trump all of a sudden is now oh
Trump's so bad because they know what's
coming well yeah she started saying that
a while ago cuz I know she knows that
that indictment was coming which she now
is of course completely flip-flopped on
and she's going to testify against Trump
and Giuliani and all the others but um I
was there at January 6th you know taking
video and I actually was visited by the
FBI and I've been vocal about this just
because I feel like it's a form of
protecting myself uh and it's it's very
scary and a lot of other journalists
there's been a lot of Talk Amongst
journalists that people that were there
that day they're coming for next so it's
a real thing and I'm not surprised by
this I and I know Steve Baker I follow
him on on social media and he's a good
journalist it's very scary what what's
going on right now in America and you
would think that reporters from CNN or
you know liberal reporters would be
saying this is wrong you should not be
you know what if somebody uh got
arrested a black lives matter rally for
covering it and there was violence there
I'm sure that they would be speaking out
against that and they don't realize that
this could flip-flop like that you know
5 years from now the political pendulum
could swing I think the other way and
they could be arrested the Owen Shroyer
precedent he did not go in the building
right I believe that there is a strong
possibility after they start going so
look they went after Owen Shroyer why he
was bullhorn now they're going after a
journalist why narrative
control I I don't see any logical reason
why they would ignore these social media
personalities who weren't even there but
were making videos cheering it on there
were some personalities that as it was
happening were posting saying things
like why is anyone mad about this y'all
and they're like yo it was crazy people
who were there tweeting stuff that I get
but there were people who were posting
videos to tens of of people to hundreds
of thousands of people saying it was a
good thing those people are likely going
to get arrested I would say that would
be for protective Free Speech a question
the Supreme Court and so is so is what
Owen Sher did they still use it in
sentencing guidelines and what they're
going to argue is these people
facilitated and incited and that is not
protected speech they're going to say
instruction to commit a crime is not
protected speech they've already gotten
people FL that believe it or not they're
not big podcasters but there was a guy
that I know that was there that day and
he was putting stuff out on on social
media and he he had like 10 followers
and then he was in the goog in DC for a
couple but he was in he was there in
January no he wasn't he was not there in
January 6 he uh he was in DC but he
never went anywhere near the capital and
they said that because it was because of
his um actual tweets and his actual
stuff on social media and it had had
something to do with Interstate like uh
something I don't even know what they
charged him with but it was this really
weird thing like crossing State
Communications crossing state lines Y
and tweeting on social media so another
I think this is less likely but also
possible I think the indictment charging
arrest or the coercion of social media
personalities with podcast and vodcasts
I think that's 100% meaning you guys
listening I'm not going to say anybody's
names or quotes because I'm going to
leave that to them but you you can
probably think of the top of your head a
handful of people who have shows who
advocated for what was going on before
and the day of but the next thing I
think is possible is people who didn't
even go to the capital but were near the
capital will likely be charged as well
oh yeah that's what everyone's been
waiting for people text me all the time
cuz they know I report on this stuff
people that were there in DC like
Grandma Aunts Uncles and stuff oh my God
car I'm so afraid I'm so afraid do you
think that I'm going to get arrested I
was there that day I was just watching
Trump's speech are they going to come to
my house and arrest me so this sets such
a terrible precedent because in 2024 who
on God's planet is going to show up for
a political protest especially when it
involves Trump and they know this
they're just completely shock and awe
with everybody if you were in DC on
January 6th but nowhere near the capital
as you've already mentioned but were
tweeting things they come after you as
you already mentioned they did for for
for this one guy so there are people who
probably saw Trump speak never went to
the capital just left but were tweeting
things and they will say we have
evidence that you were there in DC
encouraging and inciting the people
around you to go and do this and they
did therefore you're going to get
incitement charge I will also add and I
think everybody listening to this can
name some people off top of their head
how many people have fled the country
already
several I haven't been keeping tabs is
it is it who who or is it worth talking
about I am not going to name people who
have already fled the country but uh I
think people who are listening already
know there are several people who were
there or who are in DC and they've fled
the United States yeah and the FEDS are
probably going to say that they were
accessories to the crime um this is this
is political prosecution this is my tax
dollars being sent to intimidate and
stop journalists journalism and from
people actually doing legitimate work on
the ground this guy Steve Baker just
tweeted yes I entered the capital like
about 60 other journalists quote did no
damage or parading or violence why are
we spending resources from the Federal
Bureau of Investigations that is
supposed to be going after traffickers
individuals who hurt children why are we
diverting those issues and that specific
important cause why is that cause being
ignored to go after someone who walk in
a federal building it's political prose
well no I mean I'll tell you uh you know
let's let's let's say you uh uh fry up
some bacon and burgers and other really
great food and you're you're having a
you're having dinner with your friends
and and then once you finish you don't
you don't rinse your dish right away you
just eat and hang out but after you're
done you're like ah I got all this Gunk
stuck to the pan what do you do soak it
for soak it overs yeah why because then
scrubbing it becomes easier now let's
talk about what they're doing why go
after journalists and you know bumbling
dotards because then The Purge in 2024
or 5 will be easier this is the soak
this is where they are putting
journalists in jail they're trying to
put the president in jail the former
president they're going after H uh not
just this one journalist other
personalities and they're going after
more importantly I think the scarier
thing is people who showed up an hour or
two after the events of January 6 when
the doors are open there's no Gates
anywhere and the police are letting
people in and they're call they're
charging them the same as the riers this
is soaking the pan because if they went
and tried to round up Trump supporters
in 2425 for no reason just instantly you
you you it' be chaos but they got to
soften it up a little bit more grains of
sand in the Heap now people are like oh
it's political persecution but it's
being normalized right so you do it one
at a time if if the feds went after Alex
Jones instantly you'd get you get riots
I think they're going to go after Alex
Jones I believe that Alex Jones will
likely be charged over January I think
that you know what protected him was him
on his megaphone telling everybody to go
home go home go home I guess that you
like you said this maybe stuff I don't
know I'm not aware of what he said prior
to January 6th or what people on his
show said I know he had oathkeepers on
his show and and proud Boys on his show
that were I don't think that
matters I mean like I feel bad for Alex
Jones He I do he's one of the most
politically persecuted I actually
founded an organization called citizens
against political persecution and this
was three years ago never in my life did
I think three years after the fact of
January 6th would this still be going on
we're going on 3 years now of January 6
people are getting arrested every day
there's still people in in solitary
confinement right now as we speak
sitting there pre-trial and they plan on
I'm sure using 2024 to continue to shock
in awe and arrest more Trump supporters
because I don't know what's going to
happen on the election in 2024 but if
anyone protests and if anyone dare says
it was in a legitimate election then now
they know that they you know have four
years of judicial precedent to look back
on and say you know we could just throw
these people in jail throw the key away
and nobody's going to say anything about
it cuz nobody has yeah it it's almost as
if they're trying to provoke a reaction
it's almost as if they're trying to piss
as many people off as they can because
this is egregious this is this is not
the behavior of a real justice
department this is not the behavior of
federal agents that are supposed to be
going after crime there was there was
essentially with this journalist what
what crime was was committed why are we
doing this and to me I'm thinking later
down the line like hey maybe they are
trying to really anger some people so
they react in a certain way that's going
to be more advantageous for the system
later down the line right they want to
provoke a reaction for which they can
start arresting people yep they need
another January 6th that's why I keep
saying I said over and over and over
again no violence you've got to vote and
I think there's a uh like Scott Adams
tweeted something uh I could be wrong
maybe it wasn't Scott but uh some uh
someone tweeted that Trump has the vote
margins right now that make fraud
irrelevant to the conversation his
margins when you look at Trump's vote
count in 2020 and how he was polling he
got more V than any sitting president in
history and Joe Biden got more votes
than any candidate in history and the
reason Biden got those votes for the
most great a great deal of those votes
that he gets are because of universal
mailin voting Now by all means go ahead
and believe that uh you know like sunny
huson and others were filling out
ballots for other people that's not my
point my point is the first stage in all
of this is universal mail and voting to
create the possibility of those votes
existing Trump's polling so high right
now that even if they went tenfold what
they were doing with with with TR with
with Biden they wouldn't come close and
I mean that figuratively but they had
full lockdowns Universal mailin voting
and Biden was was W was able to pull off
81 million right now there's no way even
if they have Universal mail voting and
sunny H says claims she voted for her
son again whatever that means and and
moms are doing that stuff and they're
doing ballot harvesting and ballot
chasing and all of that Trump still wins
what they desperately need and by they I
mean the neocons the neoliberals and the
Deep State the unip party establishment
what they desperately need is in 2024
there to be some kind of January 6 type
event well that's what I've been fearing
I don't you know I know something's
coming up in 2024 and I live in New York
City so I don't know if it's going to be
there and I feel like it's going to be a
false flag event I don't know if it's
going to be another pandemic or I
thought it a year or two ago when they
were doing those Invasion Alien Invasion
con Congressional hearings they were
going to tell us aliens had landed and
we all have to stay in our house or if
there's going to be a nuclear threat or
something like that but there's going to
be something big that happens in 2024 in
order to I think affect the election you
know that that I'm not a conspiracy
theorist and I'm not trying to sound
like one but I think everybody knows
that I have elderly relatives who are
liberals who say to me all the time
something's not right this I've never
seen anything so bad something bad is
going to happen something bad is going
to happen it's like we're all being
subliminally prepped somehow and
everybody keeps saying the same thing
I'm sure you've heard it something bad
is going to happen I think that
something bad is going to be in 2024 and
it's going to affect the outcome of the
election well Jones and pesobic think we
could go to full scale war with Russia
by next October and then that that would
uh right here's the funny thing you know
Roseanne says there's not going to be an
election right if we are in fullscale
World War III you may very well see a
suspended election well it's martial law
it's emergency Powers it's it's the
government saying presidential dir 51
there's there's the Poseidon tunami
weapons that have been utilized by the
Russians against the east coast of the
United States we need to mobilize all
resources they have not been used no no
I'm I'm saying hypothetically I'm I'm
going over a hypothetical situation that
could potentially unfold saying we are
in a life or death situation your rights
your civil liberties are gone they don't
matter anymore we need to make sure we
survive as a nation fighting off the
ruskis the Chinese the Iranians the the
Hezbollah whoever uh they have as the
the next Boogeyman lined up for everyone
and uh that's the trajectory that that
we are on because power is is is is not
easily let go of throughout human
history the people who have accumulated
vast amounts of power hold on to it
they're not going to relinquish it
they're not going to have look how look
what they're doing already look the the
the Donald Trump's facing 750 years in
jail they're not going to give up that
amount of power because they know if
they do they're the ones who are going
to be going to jail when Trump becomes
president so let me pull up this story
from Yahoo entertainment Hunter Biden
claims he might flee the country if
Donald Trump is elected president so
pick your poison ladies and gentlemen
look I'm going to say it Luke I'm going
to say it mhm Civil War D what about it
take a shot you've got right now
journalists being arrested the
expectation and the evidence is clear
that more journalists more personalities
they're going to keep arresting people
over January 6th that is their move in
the inverse Hunter Biden feels he has to
flee the country if Trump is elected
because if Trump is elected the
expectation is he is going to start
arresting these criminally corrupt
individuals no matter which way you cut
it neither side can accept defeat in
2024 no matter what I mean while
cohesion is a win well you got to
understand Ian the Democrats embarked on
a trajectory that there's no going back
from with this legal lawfare that they
have utilized against the Republicans uh
you you look at everything that they
have been doing it has opened up a
Pandora's Box that we see in many
developing nations we see in Banana
Republic the same kind of behavior going
after politicians going after lawyers
going after journalists because of their
political ideas and expressions that is
a very dangerous move that there is no
going back from now if there is a
transition of power and I and I say that
very carefully if there is a transition
of power why wouldn't the next president
of the United States who is a republican
use the same kind of legal lawfare that
the Democrats used and they would be at
a disadvantage now if they didn't
because they would show we and they
would allow them to get away with
essentially this larger pendulum swing
escalation that sadly uh there's no
going back from I feel like they have
everything to lose obviously Joe Biden
has everything to lose which is why he's
probably still running to protect
himself because they've committed so
many crimes with the political
persecution of course and you know the
January 6 first select unselect
committee uh was so Lawless and all of
the stuff that will be uncovered
obviously if Trump gets back in and
hopefully he would actually persecute
these people because they have committed
real crimes unlike you know Donald Trump
I don't think he's committed real crimes
and I'm not
being uh biased towards Trump but he
hasn't so I think that the Democrats
have everything to lose and they're
going to pull out all the stops to win
next next year whatever that means
they're going to pull out all the stops
I had this uh I think a lot of
presidents uh violate the laws and do
something illegal but uh they're never
held accountable for it I I would kind
of disagree with you on that point but
the fact that they are Prosecuting it
for the first time um shows the clear
escalation cuz there's previous
presidents that murdered and
assassinated American teenage citizens
uh with their own signatures with their
own with the with them personally
signing off on it so all presidents
essentially in my book are criminals and
they have committed criminal violations
against human beings against innocent I
mean I guess how could you say that
minus war crimes because war crimes are
terrible I guess like in the eyes of any
other Nation American Presidents commit
genocide commit many war crimes but I
don't think anyone's really been as bad
as Joe Biden when it comes to the
political persecution that's going going
on in America right now and the attack
of a political opponent and his
supporters and his attorneys and anybody
that voted for Trump is automatically An
Enemy of the State absolutely no of
course you're absolutely right about
that and and that's the point that we're
making here Ian you were going to say
something well I was going to say a
couple things one is I think of another
president comes in and they're like the
pendulum swinging like slow it down we
can do this together CU if we fall in
the disarray the whole world's going to
create World War III on our soil it's
going to be the roads will get like it
would be like infection start ation and
dehydration are the three main enemies
not weapons and bombs if if that happens
we cannot let that happen we got to stay
together but I have this Vision like
three or four days ago where I was like
saw the government actually like really
going and rounding people up kind of
like arresting sort of like I mean you
could kind of consider what this this
this journalist and everything and that
people cheering it on like that's like
like how they create like a like a um a
scapegoat a group of scapegoats and then
the rest of the people are like yeah and
then I started thinking of the Nazis and
how they did that to to the Jews and I'm
like just wake up wake up people wake up
it's so scary and like I always feel
like whenever I see a group being um
demonized I'm always very suspicious
like for example with January 6 how the
white male that that's like the kind of
like the midwestern really white guy
became a terrorist the domestic
terrorist there's a reason it's like the
same thing that happened after I think
the Iraq War how Muslim people were
really demonized and that's what ushered
in The Patriot Act January 6 6th and
demonizing white men ushered in this
really tyrannical stuff this judicial
precedent that nobody has any idea what
the long-term ramifications will be so
I'm always suspicious when a group is
demonized by the media and by the Deep
State let's go back to this story
because I you know if this story is true
if the sources are true here Hunter is
not wrong like if Donald Trumps becomes
president of the United States if you're
looking to to save your own kind of self
your own skin get the hell out of Dodge
and what if and what if uh Trump loses
and what if it's Nome Nome Harris or
Nome Whitmer I mean if it's Whitmer this
lady is a psychotic and deranged
murderer right uh what did why you say
that the putting covid patients into oh
oh my favorite Story the dude who
mercilessly beat that old man to death
in a Michigan nursing home remember that
one no I don't think so pull it up no a
lot of people are saying that Whitmer
could be the VP for Nome um that could
be a likely candidacy that uh would be
absolutely atrocious for the American
people 20 old beating suspect was moved
to nursing home because he has covid-19
says father Detroit so like uh many
states these Governors were putting
people who should not be in nursing
homes and nursing homes during covid and
it resulted and New York is the is the
example we all know 15,000 dead and that
was Andrew Cuomo so that's is why people
are like you think Chris CUO would come
on the show no he would never come on
the show because I got to say I'm sorry
I'm probably the only one with the balls
to say to Chris cromo your brother is a
mass murder who murdered 15,000 people
including a friend of the show whose
parents died because of what Andrew KO
did I think we got to start manifesting
that these people will come on the show
because that's the culture War if if
they won't if people refuse to talk then
we lose the cult that's the loss that's
game over if we if people refuse to
communicate it's game over sociopathic
Mass murderers uh don't usually deal
with a confrontation well they don't
deal with being confronted on their
horrible actions that have led to
tremendous human life loss uh especially
when it called out directly to it face
to face I called out a lot of war
criminals personally myself during my
journalistic career uh they don't get
happy they they I got arrested a number
of times for confronting a lot of
politicians about their very horrible
illicit actions they get mad they freak
out yeah right and in New York right now
speaking of there's a new law that they
just passed that quarantine camps like
if you're sick or if you're unvaccinated
literally this is something that Kathy
hokel put through you could be put in a
quarantine Camp against your uh against
your will so they could come to your
home knock on the the door pull you out
and throw you in quarantine
camp we talk about Hunter Biden you know
wanting to get out get out of Dodge but
then what's the uh what if what if Trump
loses now here's what I think do we get
out of Dodge well I don't think uh I
don't think Trump wins or loses I don't
think Biden Newsome whoever it's going
to be wins or loses I don't think I I I
I cannot see a reasonable conclusion to
the election I can't in 2020 we had a
lawsuit Texas V Pennsylvania with I
believe 48 states were involved in the
suit either joining in or fi filing uh
uh amicus briefs or what's what's the
proper plural Amai or whatever I don't
know the point is they're all basically
saying we we we we are we are pushing
back the only reason it stopped there
was because the Supreme Court refused to
take the case and the case fizzled which
was the Supreme Court taking sides
taking sides with Pennsylvania this left
a very sour taste in the mouths of
States like Texas
and Texas Ken Paxon goes hard and you
you've got you got Missouri as well
going after these
frauders what's going to happen at the
end of 2024 before we even get to
election day there is going to be legal
challenges to early voting there's going
to be claims of widespread fraud on both
sides the election will happen different
channels and different Outlets will
report different data people are going
to people are people are going to notice
like oh look the number changed on the
TV it went up then went down and no one
will accept it because I'll tell you
nobody accepted 2016 the Democrats said
it was Russia the Democrats actually
believed that Russia hacked the machines
in 2020 it was the conservatives who
said the Democrats rigged the machines
2024 is going to be we will not accept
this why because the Biden doj is
already weaponizing law enforcement to
arrest innocent people like this
journalist Steve Baker that's already
happening so you've got all of these
Trump Administration officials facing
criminal prosecution and they're like
Trump needs to win we have to win this
one now many of them are bowing out like
cowards that that's true but a lot of
people are like if Trump does not win
this is life or death hunter Biden
saying the same thing so it's going to
be 100,000 lawsuits from the left
100,000 from the right the courts are
going to be jammed up and I imagine come
December we don't know who won I just
don't want to rest everything on one
guy's status as president like it it's
so much about the individual loving the
the humans around them and and
sacrificing themselves for the humans
around
them in I I agree with you but for the J
Sixers it is life or death it for many
of them uh especially with a lot of them
that are in solitary confinement so I
agree with your sentiment never put any
man above yourself never worship any man
never Idol any man or or woman always
make sure to take care of yourself first
I think the bigger solution other than
voting is you being the best version of
yourself being happy being healthy being
strong being financially successful
that's the way out of this us realizing
hey we don't need government we don't
need tyranny we don't need all this
other crap all around us that they keep
trying to sell us and only works because
we keep buying it so so I understand
that that sentiment a lot but sadly with
how weaponized the political system has
become it is life or death for a lot of
individuals it is freedom or slavery for
a lot of individuals and that's those
are high stakes right there and and and
the future of this country as well to
where it is going to be from here I'm
concerned that Donald Trump's Don I'm
going to call you is like does he not
realize that like if he keeps pushing
and being like I'm going to go get them
I'm going to get that like it's making
it worse for people like the people that
are in prison it's making it worse it's
making them be like oh we need less
Trump supports because he keeps saying
he's going to come destroy like why
doesn't he tone down and start to talk
about
Unity yeah that's always the mysterious
question why Donald Trump says some of
the things he does I guess like you know
he says some things that are really out
there um I think a lot of the times he's
just saying it kind of jokingly like he
said I'm going to come after these
people but only on day one and you know
he say that he he said that or he didn't
he said on day one I'm going to drill
baby drill and build a wall he dodged
the question okay Hannity said are you
going to be a dictator and go after
these people and Trump said only on day
one we're going to build a wall and
we're going to drill so I guess see even
I am I am uh guilty of hearing fake news
because that was what I heard on the
news he said it he said when he said are
you going to be a dictator and do this
he said only on day one that was his
answer and then he went on to say I'm
cut off and they used that sound
everywhere that's what I'm saying that's
why I was under that impression and they
and they Ed these clever lines where
Trump says he will he will be dictator
only one day right and I I believed it I
believe I said he said it but he was
probably joking around you know that's
what I thought I thought it was such a
lazy way to answer the question no I
don't think he was he wasn't listening
he was not listen that's a lazy way to
answer like not listening say I didn't
hear I didn't understand what you said
please repeat the question handy was
asking are you going to use your powers
to get revenge and retribution and
Trump's not paying attention and then he
just hears dictator he goes yes to build
a wall and then kenned goes no that's
not what I asked I asked about
retribution and Trump's like we're going
to drill and so you can argue that Trump
just did not answer the question that's
the most reasonable
explanation that's it he didn't actually
answer the question about whether he'd
really be a dictator to get revenge he
answered it he just but it look question
why does Donald Trump say the things
he's saying well you know I kind of feel
like a lot of people in this country
think that when the doj is weaponized
when the farle is cart blanch you have
to actually fight back and how do you do
it Donald Trump talking is probably the
best way to do it why well we don't want
violence we don't want Civil War so a
lot of people are like we're we're going
to be reasonable we're not going to Riot
we're not going to do what black lives
matter does we are going to vote in
local uh election officials which
they've done we're going to vote in
populist candidates in Congress which
they've done in many areas and we're
going to support Donald Trump then
Donald Trump says I'm going to go after
him and I'm going to do all this but
here's the thing
that's the best possible way to actually
do it to vote for Trump and then hope he
uses law enforcement powers to arrest
criminals you could consider that as a
tactic but I think a better way is to
strengthen our economy I think that the
best way to to to solve the corruptive
issue is to make a stronger base growth
domestic product grow how do you do that
when for the past 20 years they've
extracted the GDP and send it to China
you need to I think it's hydrogen fuel
you need to alter our fuel you didn't
you didn't answer my question well um
you need to start pumping hydrogen
through the methane system does that
have to do with them sending our
manufacturing base to China how do we
make hydrogen when we don't have people
here to work factories or factories that
can do hydrogen refiner uh refining we
have some out of Rice University they're
hitting carbon trash with electricity at
7,000 degrees with flash ju Heating and
turning it into hydrogen fuel so let's
go back to the beginning what should the
American people do when for the past 20
years the neocons and neolibs have sent
our manufacturing base to China build
new manufacturing and how do you do that
by inspiring people show them what to
build who does that the a regular
American what can they what can they do
you can uh search uh James tour out of
Rice University and look at what they're
doing with creating Hy I got I got I got
a problem for you though there's an EPA
regulation barring the construction of
of factories and the carbon emissions in
this area it doesn't produce carbon
emissions I'm not talking about hydrogen
specifically I'm talking about the
manufacturing base explain what you just
said the reason people voted for Donald
Trump is because he vowed to Rel rules
executive orders and to work with
Congress to repeal laws to allow
manufacturing to return to this country
that's not the only reason that's a big
component what we end up seeing in the
first term of Donald Trump was a $3
billion reinvestment into Michigan from
auto manufacturers who brought their
factories back the reason why Trump
wanted to remove environmental
regulations like the EPA was because
this was the reason why these factories
moved in the first place they could not
actually produce things and the
Democrats they've done the perfect
perfect system of no tariffs free trade
and High regulation high taxes the
trifecta what that means is anybody who
wants to open a factory say to make
socks they're like socks produce too
much carbon EPA says no taxes are at 35%
we can't afford it however free trade
with China that means we put our Factory
in China we pump out as much carbon as
we want the socks get sent back to the
US for free and the US taxpayer dollars
and wages get sent to China instead so
what did the American people do they did
the most reasonable thing I will vote
for a representative who is going to
enact policy that will help remedy this
problem but I think bringing back the
old manufacturing is not the way because
it does produce a lot of carbon poison
like that stuff can kill carbon monoxide
if you breathe then you'll die so you
need to make new manufacturing bases
that don't produce that much carbon uh
byproduct gas wait until you find out
what the Chinese are doing as they have
coal mines they don't give a damn about
anything they had a whole recycling
program where where Canada thought they
were recycling with the Chinese the
Chinese were just dumping in into the
ocean you look at the developing nations
and and the amount of pollution that
they uh put out to the rest of the world
it is absolutely incredible but they do
that with with economic success because
of these double standards and these
stupid rules and these stupid
regulations that have a huge
disadvantage to the American people the
American worker the blue collar
individual that doesn't stand a chance
cuz every opportunity he has is being
squandered by government bureaucrats who
are saying let's just do it over there
because it's a dirty job that's that's
insane that's stupid and it's shooting
shooting America in the foot part of
what's great about this hydrogen
production is it makes the byproduct the
carbon byproduct is is in graphine form
it doesn't get lost in the atmosphere so
it you you have it as dust that you
basically can put into like cement or
concrete and get get it make it three
times stronger you can put it into
asphalt things like that this reminds me
of when I was at Occupy Wall Street they
had a Luke was there luk you might you
might remember this they had a general
assembly meeting where they were like
what's our what's our what's our number
one fix what's the problem here
and everybody kept raising their hands
and and saying the problem is the
banking system the problem is revolving
door government and then finally some
like 60-year-old guy stands up out of
turn and goes what is wrong with you
people it's fracking fracking is
everything the only thing that matters
is Fring and I'm just like that guy has
absolutely no idea how the economy Works
how the system works so you get a Donald
Trump who looks at all of these things
Mass migration lowering wages free trade
making it so that people can freely move
their factories overseas and ship in
products for free meaning cheap Chinese
wages to compete with the United States
stripping middle class jobs as well as
high environmental regulations a
multifaceted uh uh network of problems
well beyond just what I've mentioned and
has to working on that Ian then you say
we should make fuel yeah the fuel is
where is the basis of all of it it's not
it is that's why the econom is out of
control because oil is so expensive and
we're relying on Saudi Arabia we we were
where our fuel sources are running you
know why you know why ring on Saud Arab
because they sold like our our because
Joe Biden is shutting down the oil
industry which is why Trump said on day
one I drill drill drill yeah Joe Biden
shut down the Keystone Pipeline that
project as well as other projects and
immediately what happens is you get
forecasters to say hey Keystone Pipeline
is pipeline is shut down what are we
looking at in terms of the future of oil
well Supply is not going to meet demand
so the cost is going to Skyrocket okay
buy as much oil Futures and stock and
oil companies as we can all of a sudden
gas skyrockets and then when we point
out the correlation between Joe Biden
shutting down the Banning fracking on
public lands and shutting down Keystone
the media lies and says but Keystone
wasn't even delivering oil anyway and
the average American who doesn't pay
attention doesn't known goes yeah they
weren't deliv living oil anyway and then
we have the very difficult task of task
of explaining correlation between oil
Futures stock prices gas prices and oil
projects and oil investment and that's
very very difficult to do Joe Biden's an
evil man he sold us out the reason why
the cost of fuel is so high is because
he wants Saudi Arabia the Deep State The
Establishment the neocons nebs they want
foreign countries to have control
because they want to maintain the Petro
dollar which means Americans suffer we
send money overseas to Pakistan and
other countries for stupid programs like
gender studies so they use our currency
we then promis them we won't compete
with you on the oil Market but when
Donald Trump was President we were
reducing at Surplus in the United States
not to mention untapped resources in
Alaska that is why people have over
Trump oil's good it's just not it
shouldn't be the only fuel if we rely on
oil it's like it's only 120 year old
technology we need so I got to tell you
you got to V for Trump why because he's
the one who's going to make that happen
right make what happen hydrogen nuclear
energy hydrogen graphine Trump's the guy
for that he's never even mentioned those
words heard wind the wind turbines like
he the ones that kill the no it's a real
in New York it's a real thing they're
trying to make New York completely
dependent on these crazy wind turbines
ruining the beaches of of Long Island
the Southshore literally lining the
state with wind turbines and they don't
work and they have a way bigger carbon
footprint actually on the environment
than not using the wind turbines so you
know the whole green energy thing to me
is really just a scam here's what will
happen Ian you'll go to anyone in the
Democratic party or Biden Administration
and you'll say everything you said and
they're going to go we want Saudi Arabia
to maintain control in the region
because they're aligned with us we want
oil to be dominant because the Petro
dollar is how we exert control over
other nations we go to war with Iraq we
go to war with Libya because they
threaten the Petro dollar the last thing
the Democratic Administration will do is
entertain an alternate energy source
which would offset our control over the
international market it's not alternate
well continue you're talking about
asking Democrats to dismantle the
international monetary fund no no keep
it up the Swift fin cial payment system
no no you keep the oil the going all
based on Petro dollars you keep the
Petro dollar going you just add an
additional fuel supply with the hydrogen
it'll cut our GD it'll increase our GD
who else produces hydrogen at this point
the globe hasn't stepped up yet and
someone's going to start doing if it's
China we're screw whoever starts doing
it first is going to win so the reason
why the United States gives US dollars
to foreign countries is because by them
having the money they have confidence in
the money they will spend the money if
the US switches to something else all of
a sudden their money can't purchase
anything in States this is why oil is
dominant and why it is the Petro dollar
they the the the the liberal economic
order the Council on Foreign Relations
the powerful International Elites are
not going to give up a ubiquitous they
have absolute control near absolute
control over oil which exists in tons of
countries and they force them to do what
we want because of it there is one
Administration that would entertain a
new energy source that would strengthen
America and work internally and it's the
same guy who tried to pull our troops
out of the Middle East who tried to get
our who who questioned why we are paying
for NATO and who while he was president
started no new Wars Donald Trump wants
to secure our borders reduce immigration
bring manufacturing back and I guarantee
you if you when you see cash Patel
sitting here and you keep saying graphi
and 50 million times to him and Don Jr
and La Trump and every everyone else
eventually Trump's going to say we need
more efficient energy to grow our
economy and they're going to be like
well have you ever heard what this Ian
guys talking about this hyen stuff
they're doing at a Rice University let's
roll the Biden Administration is going
to say that'll threaten the Petro dollar
shut up I don't think so because the
Petro dollar will still anyone wants to
buy our resources out of the US they
still have to pay us in dollars they're
not our resources if they want to buy
Saudi Arabian oil they can still do it
in U we can still force them to do it in
US Dollars while we're producing
hydrogen at home so we produce a small
amount of hydrogen you will not create a
hydrogen-based economy unless you
disrupt the Petro dollar I don't think
so because you can use the oil and turn
it into graphing here you can sell the
oil overseas continuously for the for
the obsolete technologies that these
other countries are using and enhance
our our capabilities at
home how do you uh uh how do you
convince say like a Saddam
Hussein to only use US
Dollars me personally generally they
they done it I mean it's it's the the
economic Hitman model that's right
there's three they take three steps why
would the US compete with itself to try
and replace its own energy dominance
when it controls what other people
produce look at what they did to Iran
when Iran tried building nuclear
centrifuges they claimed it was because
Iran was trying to build nuclear weapons
I don't think so I think there's a
strong possibility Iran was trying to
create nuclear power and they was like
ain't no way we're going to let another
country develop any kind of energy that
competes with the Petro dollar I don't
think H blow them up with stuck net I
don't think it competes though that's
what I keep thinking about because the
oil is still so useful we can still pump
we should probably be pumping more oil
to be honest and then reconverting it
into graphine to reuse it so we don't
get the carbon dioxide and the carbon
monoxide but we need Plastics out of it
and you can still use it to combust but
in in addition to that there's just more
people there's more fuel tanks um and if
we don't do it first someone else will
and that's that's well the French are
becoming fully dependent on nuclear uh
Power they're they're building a crap
ton of nuclear um silos almost
everywhere the problem with nuclear is
it's not a fuel source it's an energy
source but fuel is either hydrogen
carbon or plutonium there is fuel that
you put into some nuclear reactors but
it's not transportable like portable
fuel fuel is portable that's why it's
called fuel um or why the what sign
signifies is that energy source is
portable and so nuclear is fantastic and
especially closed system recycling like
where you get thorium salt burrito
reactors that can make more thorium salt
those are great but they're they're
stuck in one in one place and then
they're you're relying on grids to get
it out this stuff you can just carry
around with you you can put eight
hydrogen uh cartridges in your battery
in your electric car and charge that
thing for 12,000 mil and then go fill it
up for 9 cents in like 13
seconds let's jump to the next subject
ladies and gentlemen we have tremendous
news you want to you want to read this
one Luke oh goodness this one triggered
me a little bit this one's from Fox
Business Southwest Airlines celebrated
for policy to give a full row to
passengers of size for free I am I am
fat and uh from now on anytime I fly I
am morbidly obese or identifying as
morbidly always uh this new policy is
apparently like Luke was saying before
the show like you walk up to the counter
and you say I'm fat so give me free
seats and they will yes ex exactly
did they weigh you beforehand there's
they I don't think they can I think
they'd be illegal I mean I always like
getting God forbid your bag is 5 lbs
overweight right this is the argument
I've been making for a very long time
cuz I've been flying uh especially all
over Europe all over the world but in
Europe they nickel and dime you any way
they can especially when it comes to
Bringing on even just the carry on which
they charge you up the wazo and I
remember my luggage was like a couple
kilos over and I'm like look how skinny
I am look at those guys over there
they're morbidly obese why are they not
paying more why am I paying more for for
my bag that wait here's what we should
do we should get like an inflatable suit
and then you walk up to the counter you
go I need extra seats when they give you
the ticket then you you poke the thing
and then you shrink down and be like
thanks for the extra seats just see what
they would do why is it a whole row Is
that real though they're really going to
give the whole row there's people doing
this there's a video of a woman with a
mask not surprisingly probably we can't
here that that you know got on to the to
the thing videotaped herself doing it
and and literally came up and said hey I
need an extra seat and people like all
right I mean not to disparage overweight
people but it is sometimes like
inconvenient to sit next to somebody
that's kind of taking a part of your
seat like i' I've had that experience
the Americans are getting bigger the
seats and in the airlines are getting
smaller uh and and it's horrible you
guys ready for this
one hi it's okay um I'm hoping to use
your um customer size policy today
customer of size yes I'm
leaving okay thank you so much for your
help she got two tickets have a seat
belt extender please and a seat belt
extender very
much thank
you what she doesn't even need it so uh
I I I'm at I don't believe they could
deny you if you ask for this so ladies
and Gentlemen please get the word out if
any of you are flying Southwest at any
point before boarding ask to use their
customer of size policy that's it and I
don't me
personally they're going to be like sir
you'll sit in the chair just fine I'll
be like excuse me I'm
overweight what's the weight limit you
going to weigh me next what so I'll take
a free seat I know so it could be
subjective I guess like who's overweight
and who isn't and like what's your like
you know body mass index ex yeah mass
and weight are not the same thing you
can be muscular and weigh 270 pounds and
just have this and this is a full flight
this was a full flight so they had to
kick someone off they to kick someone
off probably they kick people off uh out
of out of an airplanes all the time well
uh you know I just got to let you guys
know you know I skateboard a lot and for
this I have uh a large leg muscles which
puts my my my body mass index has always
been slightly higher for this reason and
uh well that means uh you know they have
to give me a free seat you're a big dude
yeah I get a free seat your arms are
pretty big too look at that yeah you
know very strong impressive you're going
to need M I'm kind of mixed what does it
mean to be of size well you know some
they I wonder if they have a definition
posted online or like weight
requirements like it's a what boxing
weight a lot of people a lot of junk in
the you know why they you know why they
did this though it's not just about
giving customers of size the option it's
that they know like when Sydney Watson
was sitting sitting between the two big
people and the I'm sorry the customer of
size she posted on it on social media
like this is messed up right so
Southwest was like listen it's wiwin if
if a customer is sitting next to them
they're both complaining right so just
give them a free seat yeah if there's
free seats on the plane I think but I
wouldn't like kick someone off a flight
for that that's crazy yeah but but like
do you want to cuddle with some like fat
morbidly obese person that's shedding
Spike proteins onto you and and sweating
on you and you got to smell their stank
for a couple hours no no I don't uh you
know what's really
funny when you fly private like it's
it's much more difficult for morbidly
obese people to fly private because they
have weight restrictions and there's no
sorry have a nice day there's no
questions this says the policy allows
larger Travelers the opportunity to
purchase an additional seat is that are
we missing something in the story is it
actually cost money no the the story is
that it's complimentary uh on Southwest
yeah on
Southwest but um yeah it says free I
guess that's how happy news for a lot of
people in America I'm being serious I
know a lot of people that will take
advantage of that yeah I I mean do you
do you want to
cuddle you know with someone with a lot
of junk in their trunk for a couple
hours it's always like for me I'd rather
sit next to someone who was not you know
I but more Americans are more than ever
obesity rates are going through the roof
heart rate disease rates are going
through the roof there's there's a
serious issue with seed oils and other
things that are absolutely atrocious
this is this is people are saying the
airline's bad here the FDA is bad here
our food industry is bad here big Pharm
is bad here those are the people that we
should be focusing on as of course they
fail us every step of the way ensuring
that we're going to be fat and sick look
fox says Southwest provided its policy
to Fox Business which said that
passengers of size have the option of
purchasing just one seat and then
discussing your seating needs with the
customer service agent at the departure
gate if it's determined that a second or
third seat is needed you'll be
accommodated with a complimentary
additional seat second or third that's
why I'm saying like get wear a fat suit
it's almost like enabling bad behavior
like Ena absolutely enabling like
obesity diabetes and everything else
remember remember on The Simpsons when
Homer realized that if he weighed over
300 lb he can work from home right so he
tries to gain as much weight as possible
so he can work for home it was almost
like during covid when people were you
know at risk it was almost like a good
thing that they were at risk I have
diabetes or you know I'm morbidly obese
because that means I'm at risk and I
could stay home and I don't have to come
in yeah there there are definitely times
when you want to cater to the weakest
among you that just for for the sake of
the tribe like keep them alive maybe for
a reason but then there are other times
when a society begins to cater to like
like if we if we have to kneecap our
entire Society in order to accommodate
people that have let their bodies become
obese that's going to be a very
challenging thing to subsist like I
don't know if we can sustain that kind
of pattern because if they keep if it
keeps propagating more and more you know
negative entropy or or whatever you want
to call it negative outcomes then it's
just this is this is going to capitalism
is supposed to
we' we've got uh some of the timcast
crew flying to amfest on Southwest uh I
think they should absolutely demand to
use the uh customer of size policy it
says here that the uh it's at the
discretion of the Southwest employees
and you may have to advocate for your
extra seat just so you're aware
absolutely and I think I think you
should and you should argue that you
have restless arm syndrome and I I would
say this oh yes I have an I have a I
have an AR arm tense tensity thing my
arms go out and you know causes me pain
if I can't stretch my arms out it's I'm
sorry it's just it is and if they say no
be like so the only criteria is that
you're obese other there there was a
viral photo remember this where the guy
had a had a belt stra to his legs and
then some woman was like a man spreader
in recovery and other people were like
it's a guy with Tourette Syndrome trying
not to kick you like that's so messed up
that you would insult him like that I
did that in an airplane I I put my I put
something around my knees cuz I fell
asleep and I didn't want to knee the
girl next to I mean what what if you
like hold on what if you said um you
know uh flight gate lady I have very
large testicles and I need to keep I
need to keep my legs spread open the
length of three seats we're all going to
be better off trust me yes somebody has
to wear a body camera and just pull all
these things and see what passes he
technically men should have bigger seats
okay we got a we got a man spread you
know we got to let the the boys we got
to let the boys breathe for our our
masculine I loved that season of the
culture War the manspreading one where
it was like a whole bunch of guys were
like the why do why do all these men
manspread and it's like you're saying a
lot about your junk right now like there
are a lot of guys that are just like I
keep my legs spread because I kind of
have to and then there's other guys be
like I don't I'm like okay I kind of get
what you're saying with that but all
right yeah you got to cool your junk uh
this is what Southwest is doing with
this particular Airline fat policy is
just a few steps away from a Wally
prophecy where people are going to be
given scooters to ride around everywhere
because they're too fat and can't move
around anywhere this is this is this is
where we are headed to as a society with
the Obesity rates this is where we are
headed not that far away from where
Wally was and uh soon W's going to be a
documentary because I want to ride
around on those things I don't I just
want to be rewarded for not you know for
taking care of my body I want to I was
actually a trainer on The Biggest Loser
what was it like and it you know so G it
gives me a lot of empathy toward
overweight people and I have I come from
a family I'm half Italian half Chinese
my Italian side there's a lot of more
really obese people on it so thank God I
have my Chinese side to balance it out
but um it's just I feel like you know
how was Biggest Loser it was it was
great working with people but they have
like decades obviously and Decades of
History uh mental history and it's very
hard to lose weight once you get to a
certain age especially like I'd say 50
like you have Decades of trauma of being
an overweight person but I feel like the
country enables it you know and not just
with uh with stuff like this but with
all this processed stuff they put in the
food a lot of that stuff is really what
causes weight weight gain all these fake
sweeteners like uh the corn syrup and
everything I think it's actually really
easy to lose
weight I I think fasting is huge for me
it is and I'm I'm lucky to say that I've
worked with people who were 500 lb and
well yes you're right that actually is
true it is very easy to lose weight it's
very easy for them to gain it right back
and and that's the issue so what we're
really talking about is yes I understand
there's glandular issues I understand
some people have metabolic 100% mental
but yo if you're just eating Lean Like
if you're eating I wouldn't even say
lean meat have yourself some fatty steak
and some greens and vegetables we go out
to eat I get a Caesar cell with no
croutons and I get a fon with extra
butter spped on Top butter all over that
steak Yeah I I keep telling Tim don't do
the greens the greens are a scam oysters
meat some fruit but that's just my diet
that's what I like well you guys are
very lucky because that that's a you
know for most people like a Frank foter
is protein you know what I mean like
that's like in the in the country
especially with the economy I AG I agree
that's what they think protein is or
people people what what Norman Boro I
think is going to we'll go down in
history okay well he probably won't uh
uh but I think he should go down history
as a as a as a welltoo but bad person
Norman Boro famously increased the crop
yield of I think it was probably wheat
you can fact check me on this one and it
it what what he did was he's like now we
can produce more wheat and feed more
people the only problem nutrition
density doesn't change so the starch
content increases the nutrition content
decreases what happens now is poor
people need to eat something like four
or five times the amount of food to get
the same nutrient level so if you're not
getting enough selenium or zinc or
whatever in your system you're just
slamming boxes of craft macaroni and
cheese cuz your body is desperate to
find it you're getting fatter and fatter
and fatter that's true however there is
the poor diet so when I was in LA I lost
a lot of weight because all I would eat
was tomatoes on tortillas with
mayonnaise well you you were cuz most
people would eat like cup of noodles or
reron you know I couldn't afford cup of
noodles I went to the local um Super
Marcato and I would get like three or
four tomatoes for like 30 cents then I
would get like a pack of corn tortillas
ingredients corn water for like 50 cents
and then I would get a little mayona
mccormic mayona or whatever it was for
like 80 cents and I was like I've got
food for the next few days and that's
all I would eat now I'm not suggesting
people actually do that when I say that
it's easy to lose weight I'm
saying you just you it's let me say this
I mean relatively to what people expect
of weight loss you know
Chris Christie is not a poor person
right he is a man of great means yet he
is still morbidly obese and says I don't
know how and it's like well dude I got
to be honest you you perhaps it's a
glandular disorder that you can't
overcome fine fair point he did get the
bypass surgery but there are a lot of
people I've met who have the capability
to eat a steak and a salad and they
choose to have a large Coke and a bowl
of french fries and a cheeseburger yeah
Chris he didn't get a i it wasn't a
heart bypass it was a gastric bypass
gastric by that's where you like tighten
a belt around your stomach okay just I
think that's what it was right a lot of
the food also is chally it's chemically
engineered to be addicting and to hit
the pleasure centers in your brain but
this is also a larger distinction
between individuals who prefer
short-term pleasure over long-term
pleasure because it's insane what people
are willing to do for just five seconds
of like mouth pleasure how much they're
willing to hurt themselves later down
the line how horrible they're going to
be feeling later down the line there's a
reason those Taco Bell memes are real
after you eat them how it just goes
through you like like a freaking garden
hose exploding everywhere do you see you
see Andrew Tate's tweet where he was
like I don't enjoy eating he's like I
just eat to get it done cuz you have to
do it and all these like fat leftists
are making fun of him and I'm like yo
that dude is like solid muscle and a
world champion kickboxer you don't got
to like him for any of other stuff but
like when the guy's talking about
Fitness and if you want to be fit you
take advice from a guy who knows what
he's doing but they made fun of him for
it exactly again as a human being this
is something that I even had problems
with myself especially when I was young
cuz no one really kind of you know told
me to to consider this or to think about
this because I was you know going after
those Arizona green teas that are filled
with high fruit doose corn syrup I was
eating a whole bunch of crappy sugary
Foods because of that that that pleasure
that I was getting really quick off of
just just hitting it but but then I I
started to realize I feel like crap
afterwards why is that that's not worth
it and and once you kind of trick your
mind to say hey I'm GNA have long-term
pleasure happiness and success through
eating food that actually is nutritious
and good for me life changes a lot of
people I don't think have that common
sense and it's just sad and I think it's
like a sister really is if there's a
systematic problem in America it's with
people being overweight and I'm not
saying it's not their fault but it's
just a systematic problem like the food
like you go to the store and everything
that's marked healthy or Diet food is
not diet food it's all lies and these
people like they're believing the
marketing and it's very sad and there's
no education program really out there
exposing these lies so let let me tell
you I think sugar is gross I cut it out
a couple years ago and and do very
little sugars we drink these these spin
drifts these are great my favorite drink
oh there's a bunch in the fridge three
three gram of sugar in this and 15
calories this is what soda should be a
little bit of juice with with carbonated
water and they taste amazing you can
always add some honey from what I
understand too those things have a a
liner so that aluminum doesn't leech
into the actual well the plastic is
worse than the aluminum is BPA free
maybe I don't know I I I was reading the
mar for that can's line with plastic I
would not be I don't know if it's
plastic but it's a liner that supposedly
blocks like the aluminum from leeching
into the drain but that sounds like
marketing cuz I'd rather have the
aluminum than the plastic but either way
but that tastes my point is this it does
it's good I stop drinking sodas and
sugar I can't drink soda it's
disgusting like the the way I would
describe it to someone who's who's
drinking soda regularly imagine just
having a glass of maple syrup yeah I
just can't I mean it tastes worse now
that they use the hyen corn syrup in it
like when real sugar was being used it
tasted but like if you compare Coke
Coca-Cola when has sugar and when has
the corn syrup inic Coke Mex it's so
good it's better it tastes better but I
I I get massive headaches when I drink
sugar it's a big deal sugar there's a
lot of different types of sugar that's
part of the problem too there's glucose
everyone needs that simple sugar then
there's like sucrose that's table sugar
that's some you know arguably okay in
small doses then there's like high
fructose and aspartame which are like
these concocted things over the last 30
years synthetic in am everything yeah
the amount of sugar in in Starbucks in
in Dunkin' donuts with their coffees is
absolutely through the roof and they
keep adding more and more and more
there's some drinks with 75 grams of
sugar and people just consume it like
like it's nothing because they don't
think oh I'm drinking they don't
understand how much crap they're
actually putting into their bodies and
destroying their liver I want I want to
I want to push back a little bit on what
you said Luke though about short-term
versus long-term gain I think you're
mostly right but I went to a local
Mexican restaurant and I got steak
fajitas and I think it was like 12 bucks
and yo I got to tell you that's
short-term pleasure dude steak steak
steak fajita and it was not expensive
and it was marinated steak sliced into
strips grilled with peppers and onions
and I'm like right there you got a low
carb healthy protein dense meal and it
was only like 12 or something bucks well
they you would think if they really
cared about the health of America this
is what I said throughout the pandemic
when they were really pushing you know
the vaccines uh why aren't they pushing
more programs telling people to how to
cook inexpensive healthy meals like
grill meat for your family there's too
vegetables but I can give you some
advice you are the carbon that they want
to reduce if you want to go cheap if
you're know if you got like 30 or 40
bucks a week that you want to buy on red
lentils I'm looking at right now at
Walmart they're $218 a pound and you can
get like buy them in bulk this is what
you want to do you want to buy food in
bulk you want to get like red lentils
maybe and a vegetable like um sliced
mushrooms or like sliced cream Peppers
you know just get them get enough of it
and then salt and a little and olive oil
get a big thing of olive oil you're good
to go man you can you can you heat those
those lentils up and then you boil them
they turn into like a paste that you can
add vegetables to freaking delicious and
protein dense it sounds great yeah most
people don't even know what lentils are
it's like it's very sad and it's very
scary like the best things to eat are
are um things that have one ingredient I
say like lentils have one ingredient
lentils you know oranges are have one
ingredient oranges and people are eating
this stuff with like 20 or 30
ingredients that are labeled as healthy
food like I have many relatives that are
like oh I I have this like healthy
cereal see it says healthy choice on the
box and it's not healthy at all if you
look at the 30 ingredients or 40
ingredients that go into it also if you
want to kick those lentils up a notch
get some oregano and cumin hey don't
listen to these guys it's all fake news
it's all propaganda what you need is
beef lever and steak that's all you need
you can add then Meats into the lentils
and things like that of course if the
things you like you hear crazy stuff and
you don't know if it's right or wrong
that lentils and tomatoes are bad for
you because of the the shells that they
have on them so you're hearing all that
information so who knows what's right in
you got to boil them into a pace the red
ones the red lentils is where it's at
but I mean it's just like if you're in a
desperate time right now with food and
you want to eat healthy I think lentils
are like a great basic based to I make
lentil burgers believe it or not like
you make that past into burgers and you
just put them in the in the freezer you
have I like burgers nice you know what
you do you know I I I love
Carpaccio carach just give me the raw
beef I don't want it cooked you know you
know what I love I I I I I can never
order a steak blue I just couldn't do it
but I love it when they accidentally
undercook my medium rare and give it to
me rare just cuz then I have an excuse
to be like oh look at that you know Seth
Seth WS was saying that yesterday Red
rare rare meat he said raw meat he was
joking but he was like no I mean medium
rare medium rare rare but you like rare
too I I I like rare better but I guess
you're supposed to get it medium rare
it's the proper way to do it I always I
always say Chef's Choice and they go
medium rare I say okay do you guys if
they do I usually get well done cuz
blood grosses me out I'm not going to
lie there's no blood it's not blood it's
not blood the red coloring of the meat
just it's not blood hemoglobin or
something whatever that red is what is
the red it's uh what is it amalin or
something I don't know some protein it
reminds me of blood I guess so I don't
but uh if I get if I order a steak
myoglobin mix of water and protein it's
not blood W good for if uh if if I order
a steak medium rare and it's medium send
it back if I order medium rare and it's
rare I enjoy it I'm kind of feeling a
rare meat right now there's nothing
better than a ribeye with all that fat
on there it's so freaking cows are such
beautiful
animals so amazing wow cow I see why the
Hindus worshiped the cow they didn't eat
it though are you sure yeah I knew I
knew I knew a har Christian a guy and I
asked him about it and he was like the
cow is your mother it provides you milk
and sustains you don't eat your mother
and I was like
okay I I do I I I eat beef I don't know
I guess you call whatever you want all
right we're going to go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to tim.com click join us
become a member cuz that members only
uncensored show is coming up in just uh
uh 20 or so minutes going to be a blast
and also you know throughout the show
I'm getting notifications on the
marketing play that we're going to be
rolling out for this next week with uh
the new song Together Again by Smoky
Mike and the god king and I don't want
to say too much but I'm just I'm just
laughing in I'm trying not to laugh too
loud but this is going to be fun uh
we're working on a press
release that's all I'll say and then
tomorrow I think I I'll I'll post it so
you can all see it but it's going to be
it's going to be really really funny so
if you want to support our work go to
the best song ever.com buy the song for
69 cents and when you do you will also
get a unique coupon code for cast
brew.com where you can get 35% off all
cast purchases for two weeks and if you
subscribe to subscription in that time
frame you will get 35% off every month
forever in fact we're actually setting
it up so that if you subscribe to the
cas Brew Coffee club with this promo
code and then say maybe in 3 or 4 months
you cancel at any point ever if you
resign up with your original information
like your same email we will relight up
that that that 35% discount so uh let's
roll man we're going to have we're going
to have a lot of fun the daily wire is
uh uh working with us on the marketing
for this so it I hopefully it'll be
really big and I guess uh we're going
for Pie in the Sky I mean the the dream
would be to hit the high 100 and get a
gold record or something I listen to the
song three times last night laying in
bed going to sleep good sure let's read
some super chats Clint Torres says howdy
people howdy Clint you're always the
first Clint Tim P says second place is
for the best uh for the best loser also
interested in franchising Casper coffee
how could we do that I know a guy who
might be interested we are moving very
close to whatever it is we need to do in
order to have more than one Casper
location and I have to wait until I can
say anything because um finalizing
paperwork and there's laws I had an
email from from coffee lady is that
public should I announce it publicly if
you want to do stuff like that no okay
we can't do anything until we have
finalized the legal paperwork for
franchising so we're waiting for uh Chef
GRL which everything's moving forward
he's the expert we're really excited and
then phase two uh after we we launch
this we are looking to open shops for
other uh prominent creators so like you
know Luke's health and wellness yeah
that's like what his house is yeah
absolutely oh it is like Luke's got
every supplement you've ever heard of
good if you're in the business you got
to try everything out so imagine when
we're when we're creating the anti-time
square here's the here's the Big
Challenge uh everybody's interested I've
talked to a lot of people about
anti-time Square in Williamsburg and
they're all like yes count me in and
then I'm like okay we need someone to
manage the whole project and connect the
dots and everyone's shrugs and the only
reason it's not moving faster is because
we need basically the head of the anti
Time Square project to do it maybe it's
as simple as me hitting up Michael
Cipher and being like can we hire a guy
to run this program and do it and then
probably yes I I think uh I think I
might know a guy all right let's roll
because it's not just about cprw imagine
the whole downtown strip of Martinsburg
West Virginia is like anti-time Square
the Public Square where you've got you
know Zubie's gym and uh Luke's health
and wellness cousin te's Diner Papa
Jack's Pizza Shack and it's like you got
to plan a weekend if you want to hit all
of these stores and see products by your
favorite personalities I should do Ian's
Playland where it's a place where kids
go and learn science have like science
toys and mechanisms they can play on I
kind of feel like a game game gaming
thing would be better yeah that'd be
cool and like yeah gra is awesome and we
had this place called Kai in Ohio where
it was like multi floored and every
floor was like a different like one was
like an Old West theme and then the next
one was like a a space theme and you had
like you tried to draw the outline of
Ohio with the it was so cool all right
Jacob parody says I think Matt Walsh
made an excellent point about budlight
in his video I'm not entirely sure $100
million to UFC is Victory it's it's
certainly a step towards Victory but it
doesn't settle the initial cause and
that's fine and I'll tell you this my
view is based on what can we do to win
and I've got bad news uh Kid Rock is out
Dana White has sided with budlight and
Joe Rogan and Shane Gillis and basically
all of Joe's friends have sided with
budlight on more than one occasion so
you can choose to stand against these
individuals Joe Rogan especially I think
he said it was stupid and he doesn't
know why people are I don't know the
exact quote but he was like it's dumb
and so my view is just kind of like when
the left pushes someone in the middle to
the right the right should respond with
hey man we're we're we're the good
people we're here for you we're nice and
we're reasonable
when they do something bad and the right
pushes them and they freak out the right
will still need to be like don't worry
we're not going to push you away because
the point of that Meme is that the left
will shove people in the middle to the
right and then not let them back and
start yelling at them and screaming at
them why are you siding with the right
my concern especially is by all means
never buy budlight again but everyone
needs to recognize it's not over
budlight is going to make moves come
April and you've got the likes of UFC
Joe Rogan and Kid Rock all coming out
now saying it's over Kid Rock saying we
gave him a black guy we did what we
needed to do and now you know we've we
we've basically won but by all means if
you don't buy it if you don't want to
buy it I'm just saying there needs to be
a strategy for what's the next move
especially with Joe Rogan posting a
video he posted a photo of them with
like 30 or 40 cans of Bud Light that was
too far what are they doing I mean I
guess Money Talks a huge amount of money
that that bud Lake gave UFC and he's
really yeah he's good friends with Dana
you know but he's a Liber like he's like
sort of liberal Joe Rogan I think he's
like oh who cares they had a a
transgender person on a beer can I don't
care I don't see what the big deal is
like that's his whole attitude towards
it I feel like we're trying to win a
culture war and we're trying to win
control of the narrative and we're
trying to convince people that this is
the side to be on because the left is
crackpots and they're crazy Joe Rogan
just posted a video I'm sorry a photo of
him with all of these beer cans I feel
like now your opportunity is to stand in
front of that photo laugh and say hahaa
we won all of you when you get woke you
go broke but we're cool chill people so
now that you've started funding our
friends we'll we'll declare Victory
that's why Joe Rogan is C celebrating
Bud Light because he agrees with us
instead everyone's saying I disagree
with Joe Rogan he's wrong and you're
going to find yourselves on the opposite
side on on the on the minority side and
then the the boycott narrative is going
to fail but by all means do whatever you
want to do I mean how's Target doing is
is it doing better now did they ever
recover I don't know I think they're all
still down and I I suppose the issue is
I like a lot of people are arguing like
the end goal is that budlight has no
money and I'm like well the end goal is
for me that any single Corporation says
We Don't Go Near insert X group of
people because they will destroy our
business if conservatives are saying we
will destroy your business then you're
going to get what what were we talking
about earlier
um uh Lil was it Lil
Nas he was he the one who did that that
Old Country Road or whatever yes yeah
that that's the longest number one on
Billboard Chart history fascinating he
had the biggest hit ever and what did he
do right afterwards he made a video
where he was banging Satan and he put
his blood and shoes basically spitting
on every single conservative why cuz the
music IND industry said you're number
one you're the best and these guys will
never buy your product anyway he said
okay then let's double down on
everything that will piss them off why
it'll generate press for us in the other
direction and and push other groups to
to spend money on us my concern is when
they realize that the the right is a
dead Market they'll say okay well then
how can we maximize the left let's let's
let's reach out to them I guarantee you
the HRC glad and other organizations
will go to Bud Light and say you double
down on the beer cans and we will push
everyone to support you every new news
organization every politician every
Democrat and they might just go screw it
we lost the conservatives in the never
coming back roll Maybe I'm Wrong
whatever do whatever you want to do all
right let's grab some more Super chats
Andre tesu says bill c21 has just passed
in Canada rip gun ownership look it up
it's bad phasing out handguns and Center
fire semi-autos wow wow so
everything man Alpha turkey says Tim the
red heer needs to be 2 and A2 years old
it turns that in 2024 which is 7 years
including 2024 before the 230 sdgs
exactly 2,000 years after Christ died
and
resurrected oh
boy red what oh it's like a Biblical
prophecy the red heer is a prophecy for
the for the second coming or the if
you're if you're Jewish it's the Messi
Messianic era the coming of the Messiah
and if you're Christian it's a second
coming right right right so what is he
saying he's saying that you need a pure
red heer
for the Third Temple for the Messianic
era and there's a group claiming that
they have a pure red heer which is never
you know it's really hard to make they
they tried they tried engineering them
but right a red heer that's like an an
animal it's a cow Red Cow female cow is
a heer a red cow with no blemishes and
it's pure red and that's never there's
never been a female unblemished heer in
history let uh there have been but they
need it for they need it for I believe
it would be the third time so it comes
on it's once every few thousand years
get them and so you have groups that are
trying to genetically engineer them I
don't think that that would count if it
was genetically enger it it does yeah
the the argument among these groups is
that the require so there's two ways to
look at it one is that it's a sign the
other is that it's a requirement right
so you can you can you can argue like if
you see the cow that means it's going to
happen whereas others say I would like
this to happen then bring me the cow the
uh the heer is a mature female C cattle
that has not given birth could you
imagine if they had the perfect heer and
right before it happened some guy took a
bull in and impregnated it and they're
like no they you say don't let it give
birth you think they just abort the yeah
maybe because it's all technicalities
man okay ready to rumble says tap
dancing is better than
skateboarding shots fired that that is
an opinion you are allowed to have I
have no argument because you are allowed
to believe that you will you are always
allowed to believe that and I respect
that you feel that way thank
you are allowed to like and not like
things man I don't I I've got no beef
with t dancing I think it's I think it's
cool I think people are good at it I
just don't enjoy it so I don't listen to
it I don't watch it and I'm like not
interested I thought fossy was really
awesome I watch Street League Super
Crown uh Sal Paulo today it's like from
two weeks ago but I was just like man
that was amazing what is it the the it's
like watching baseball but for
skateboarding you know what I mean yeah
so you're like you're watching a skate
contest yeah dude um who was it um was
it Giovani someone did a fakey front
sidew to back Smith down the big
handrail and the the the commentators
the judges were just like that is not a
trick people do and it it's a it's a
it's a gnarly trick he he basically won
because of it B yeah you jump backwards
blindsided onto a rail it's just it's a
crazy trick I don't know man doesn't
seem like it's the craziest but like if
you skate you're like what the amazing
stuff anyway watch your tap dancing
videos sounds like they're
fun Golden Fleece game says of course a
Christian named Michael would strike
down
Satan that's a good
one here we go Zer Zer creete creation
says hey everyone this has nothing to do
with the topic but I do love timcast I'm
from Wisconsin and I make cool concrete
statues with music and just started a
channel would love everyone's support
right on what was the channel zuper cre
creations you know what I've always
wanted to do is is clay pottery I just
love watching those videos the dude just
like puts his hand and then it turns
into a pot you know what I mean like
it's like a big a big ball of
clay you can do the pedal or an electric
one I've been looking at pedal's better
you get you can get a both so you can do
both but like you you're exercising but
like you have this mound of clay and the
guy puts his hand in the middle and then
it just starts hollowing out into a ball
that looks like so much fun dude clay
talking about getting Primal clay
pots yeah so much fun and then we got to
do glass blowing yeah my buddy did that
for a living He wrecked his lungs but he
was good at it what are you middle-aged
Housewives come on now like you got to
learn skills survive what are you going
to do when the collapse happens Luke and
you're like how am I going to make a
beaker I don't I don't want any of your
Beaker you don't want any Beaker I don't
want no Beaker D we sprinkle some graph
to Dr Stone we should experiment with
this stuff in the clay the graphine and
see what if it gets stronger Luke's
going to be eating wild boar and I'm
going to be riding around on a
motorboat I'm going to be fishing with
with technology and Luke's going to be
like get out of here you know I got a
sharp stick and I'm going to be like I
got a glass Beaker so I can separate 56
I'm going to take what you got no you're
not I'm like how are you going to make
5.56 if you don't even know how to make
any of these things I'm going to be in a
bat cave scooping up bat poop being like
I'm getting ready yo I'm going to be
making food alchemizing lentils good
good luck give me some salt and I'll
take you there you're going to need
it Doomsday Machine says the description
of the tenants and origins of Satanism
make it sound more like an anti-religion
than a genuine religion yeah they
basically worship themselves sounds like
something Ian would be into what no I
always thought atheists kind of
worshiped themselves they do it's like
to me it's like how could you be so
arrogant to think that you sort of just
appeared without any divine intervention
from a greater power yeah it's it's it's
midwit I describe no offense to atheists
you're allowed to believe it I'm not
saying but I I I I there's this meme
where you got the IQ bell curve and the
very bottom it's the guy who looks like
he's not all bright and he's like God is
is real then you've got the guy on the
on the high end of the IQ wearing a monk
robe saying God is real and the guy in
the middle crying saying no God's not
real and I I do kind of feel like that's
how that's how it is yeah I was that
midwit in the beginning there's no
unless you can prove it it's not real
but the issue the issue around God is
for the midwit and midwit are not stupid
they're slightly higher IQ the
assumption is that God must be a man in
the clouds as as opposed to a force
Beyond human comprehension with yeah
there there's a million in one ways to
describe but but like the first thing
anyone needs to do on this journey from
atheism into belief in God is
einsteinian God and understanding that
concept that God does not need to be a
man in robes and if that's how you
envision it you have a very limited
perspective on what the concept of God
is and I would actually encourage you to
look into and read about infinity and
that's where it's at right I mean well
most people can't even conceive of what
Infinity means like I can't conceive of
the universe and Infinity people think
Infinity is a number and that's science
though that's science people say oh you
know the universe and there's this black
hole and there's these galaxies and I
just can't conceive it actually
overwhelms me at night when I think
about it but I can actually conceive of
God more than I could conceive of this
fathom this endless universe fathomless
is a good word the uh if you expand away
from a platform super fast but it's also
expanding and getting bigger super fast
so it's like it seems like it's staying
the same shape but you're getting
further away as it's getting bigger
that's kind of well that's science right
and people believe that but uh they
don't really know what it means it's
like a meditation I do and then it opens
up something in the back of your brain
it's pretty cool
ponyup says satanists are a
counterculture lucif lucifans are the
Secret order types trying to re-engineer
society through a death cult Lucifer
rebelled against God and was cast being
renamed Satan or adversary
interesting Lucifer the lightbringer
ready to rumble says Ian why don't you
ever talk about talk is about Muhammad
why is it always Jesus I don't know a
lot about Muhammad maybe you should read
yeah I I was listening to the Quran a
little bit Serge was like you're
listening to in English that's heresy I
like a I've got to get there somehow
where's that where's that billong at
Serge wow I guess it's someone's going
to get a fat on their head I mean I love
M anyone that can rally people and unify
people I'm I'm well I should be careful
about that because Hitler kind of did
that too so maybe not anyone but yeah
Muhammad seems like a fascinating guy
and I hear that it was actually a
woman's lib movement a women's rights
movement in the beginning oh goodness
you mean the Muslim Prophet yeah the
Islam itself like women didn't have much
power in that area of the world that
time and then after Islam was created
they were able to um run the economies
of their of their husband's houses so
they became like much more empowered in
the community and then over the years
they say like like any religion it's
been co-opted by politics and stuff well
I I guess everybody's been kind of
looking more into the Muslim religion
because of everything going on right now
to see what it really is and I think
it's interesting that uh they actually
have a book of Mary that tells the story
of Jesus and there's a lot of parallels
to the Bible that I didn't know we in
there so it's really interesting
actually I would love to have a Muslim
scholar on I I don't know if you ever
looked into that but it's it's
interesting the book of Mary there's the
book of Mary in the Quran that says you
know that there was a virgin named Mary
that had a son named Jesus and they tell
basically the same parallel story to
that of that in the
Bible yeah Muhammad was a big fan of
Jesus as far as I can tell and and a fan
from what I understand he was like
somehow friends with St Katherine of
Sienna of the Catholic church it's
really how all these things crisscross
is so fascinating to me like the three
religions Judaism uh the Muslim religion
and Christianity they all do this crazy
crisscross and they all repeat the same
story so there has to be some truth to
that to to what they're saying I think
so like God they they tapped into like
the unifying concept must be the same
guy in my opinion yeah let's grab some
more Super chats what have we he the
voice of the people says Jack Smith told
the SC he believes that bush and Obama
can still be prosecuted because
presidential immunity ends when they
leave office to get Trump he opened the
door for that if SC agrees Supreme Court
uh I'm game me too yeah all of them I
hope Donald Trump say say okay and then
when he gets elected he just starts have
he gets oh man could you imagine AG cash
Patel oh my goodness I would love to see
Bush prosecuted for war crimes and Obama
prosecuted for everything he did to the
Press what if Trump was like I will go
to jail in on as president I will arrest
myself and everyone else but he like
goes with them he get pardon you're
saying that Donald Trump would sacrifice
himself for the sake of all of the
United States like I did illegal things
while I was President as well so we're
all going to jail what if what if what
if Trump said kindar that he would allow
himself to be prosecuted but only if
Bush and Obama are prosecuted for their
crimes as well and all of the people of
this country would be pardoned of their
wrongdoing gosh that's an interesting I
think CRI Trump would take all of the uh
penalties of all of the crimes that's
like a Jesus metaphor I think his I
think his crimes would be like mere
misdemeanors and violations while Bush
and Obama would be like type class A
felonies I don't know there's uh that
there's an operation warp speed that I
think is worth investigating let me read
this one from Dr Oldsmobile he says
howdy crew Ian your talk of the radio at
the beginning and the new song coming up
tomorrow made me think of Spirit of
Radio of Love Love Letter radio but also
a critique of the music industry a lot
of the lyrics still hold True to this
day rip Neil Spirit of Radio yeah
basically the music industry
is probably one of the most captured
institutions there's a lot of indie
films indie films do fairly well but and
you can get indie films on Amazon and
you can get indie films on other
platforms I I turn on Amazon all the
time and I see these movies that are
just total trash and I'm like how did
this movie get on Amazon and they've got
a really great like screenshot thumbnail
or whatever you'd call it for the movie
and it's like really awesome art with a
crazy description and then you turn it
on and it was filmed on like a Sony
handicam from Best Buy for 500 bucks and
it's just a trash movie that was made
for like $20 and I'm like what is this
the music industry however you're you're
you're not getting on these lists even
when we published Our Song properly for
some reason it wasn't appearing on the
iTunes lists oh how about that oops they
forgot to track these these analytics
it's kind of like trying to get an Oscar
I'm just done with that that path
anymore like they're they're they're
they're basically like Cults yeah it's
like you have to bend the knee to the
guy the people in charge it's the same
it's the same thing with everything
right Kevin McCarthy is is using the
weight of the GOP against people who
wanted to challenge the The Narrative of
of the party he was backstabbing
Republican uh candidates who were who
are part who were populist that's the
game you have to then go to him and say
I will do whatever you say just don't
hurt me right this is how the game is
played well we're breaking that game
they can't stop us if we sold 500,000 of
these songs Not only would we make a lot
of money but Smoky Mike and the god king
as well as timcast music would receive
gold records from their institutions and
their Industries you got to put it
behind you I would be awesome I I I
don't know how we sell 500,000 that's a
really hard thing to one sale at a time
one sale at a time and and the thing is
like a lot of these records it's over a
long period of time you know it's like
you put out a song Someone put out a
song and like 5 years later they finally
sold 500,000 can you gift song purchases
like buy one for your family every
member of your family it it only tracks
if you buy it for yourself if you could
you'd get an artist who's like I'm gonna
gift a million songs and then it would
all be just it's all bunk there are you
know there are ways they play the game
but you know it's whatever I mean I
think our strategy is is the best one we
give coupons off on coffee yeah because
the the secret is there are a lot of
people who never bought our coffee maybe
now they will cuz they're getting a big
discount and it's good for cash this is
a good one this song is like it's Poppy
it's but it's like a one that you would
want to buy that's the cool thing about
it like it's really good I don't know
car it's Carter's Niche like really good
at Electronica it's like the weekend
basically if you like the weekend it's
it's like the whole gag is we were like
let's just take modern synth pop and
then make a version of it that was
together again from Smoky Mike and the
god king to like mock the music industry
and it's two vocalists we'll talk about
it more once it's released so people
know the reference of what we're saying
but having two guys go back and forth in
a song is like much needed these days
absolutely two guys singing together
about how we just need to come together
that's what the song's about that's what
it's all about yeah I'm really excited
for this all right here we go Bender the
offender says with the obesity rate in
America they have to balance the plane
out by putting fat people on each side
but this is true so when we fly private
they actually they they you have to give
your weight so they're like okay how
many people are flying give us the
weight of all the passengers because
they have to know the weight of the
plane for bigger planes you can't have
all the people on one side it would
shift the way to the plane so that
that's why a lot people don't understand
this you'll be an empty plane and people
will be scattered in their seats because
it'll assign them in such a way to
balance the plane and then if everybody
runs from one side to the other the
plane could like it could Wobble the
plane I don't know about today if it
take it down or anything like that but
yeah
all right what do we have Rett teaser
says Tim I was a studio art major in
college with my main discipline in
function Pottery always go electric on
the wheel foot pedals don't keep
consistent speed leading to unleveled
Pieces well yeah I'm not talking about
actually making good Pottery I'm talking
about having fun and just like getting
that workout as you're as you're
pedaling and then making a goofy looking
little thing that you can put on a shelf
yeah I think that there are pedals that
do both so you can turn the power off
and just pump it yeah or if you get the
right gear
ratio you could be able to give it a
longer stable period but yeah Electric's
going to give you the steady spin all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to the best
song ever.com buy the song it's only 69
cents and you will join us in our
Collective you know what this is It's a
Spirit Bomb like Goku and Dragon Ball Z
you know what I'm talking about a little
bit Serge does he's like yeah when Goku
is like I'm going to defeat Vegeta
everybody lend me your power for 69 you
buy the song you check it out and it
helps us uh helps the daily wire crew
but shout out to Jeremy boring and
Michael nolles and the rest of the crew
the daily wire because I'm talking with
their team and they're going they're
going to go ham on marketing as well
we're going to put be we're going to be
putting a ton of money in marketing for
this one just because uh like the other
thing I announced is we're doing the
boonies prizes so we're going to be
awarding $10,000 every year to the top
skateboarder of our choice that's it and
it's not going to be industry Pros it's
going to be like somebody who did
something truly incredible I view it
like the Pulitzer prizes the Pitzer
prizes of skateboarding and then maybe
even in the first year we could do BMX
scooting rollerblading and skateboarding
and give a 10K prize to people who
pushed the pushed the industry or the
sport in some way I think that would be
really really big you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast G do you want to
shout anything out yeah sure if you want
to follow me that would be great on
Twitter follow me at car castanova I'm
currently suing Facebook because they
banned me for life but eventually I'll
hopefully be back on there and uh watch
Newsmax on Saturday nights um I'm on a
show cold Wise Guys with John tobacco
and definitely subscribe and read the
Gateway ponded it's a great publication
that I also write for and I'm always
writing breaking news on there sweet
Cara thank you so much for for uh coming
on uh my website is the best political
shirts.com the stickers come off on the
members area and ladies the price is
going up in 2024 just warning you time
yeah yeah yeah inflation biomics the and
and supply and demand here there's not a
lot around that again the best political
shorts.com I also have the best
political show.com uh it would be cool
to reach a million subscribers you guys
can make that happen subscribe on the
best political show.com thank you so
much for having me it was great man the
show was awesome it was like extreme
downs and then extreme UPS I had a lot
of fun it was dark and it was light all
at once it's a roller coaster just like
life join me as well at Ian cross and I
interviewed Ashley stclair other day we
had a lot of fun we went for like an
hour and a half it was super cool so
follow me on YouTube and M and Facebook
and even though you're and then uh
Instagram and x and Rumble follow me on
all those platforms bye uh I am
surge.com find me on the internet all
over the place uh Twix is the best
Cheers guys we'll see you all over at
timcast.net
I